This is Jocko podcast number one 57 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
I was in a seal platoon serving as the assistant platoon commander in the late
nineties.
Note that means yes,
no war going on.
That's what it means.
So we were training,
we were training hard and this platoon that I was in at the time,
we were going through urban training,
urban combat training and we are pretty far along in the training and we were
starting to get our,
our simunition,
which is like fake bullets are simunition in paintball wars on force,
on force training.
And we were doing um,
like multiday operations.
So almost like a scenario,
like you've got a full scenario going on.
Like there's bad guys in the city.
No,
it's the concrete city,
the fake city with concrete buildings that are pretty much just the shells of
buildings and we're going against op for seals.
We call them all up for that stands for opposing force.
So the opposing force there,
other seals who are role players pretending to be bad guys.
They know our tactics,
they know our techniques,
they know our procedures.
And on this particular day they had captured one of our seals from our platoon,
the bad guys,
the role players.
Was that part of the scenario or just a made it part of the scenario.
So whatever they did they'd cause confusion.
They cause mayhem.
They end up with one of our guys just on their own though.
That wasn't part of the overall training?
Well it is.
You know,
when I was running training we always did that too.
So it's just a long standing kind of hey if you can capture one of the seals,
it's like never leave a man behind.
Let's get him to leave a man.
It's captured.
So at this point,
like I said,
they had,
they had captured and I don't remember exactly,
but they'd captured 100 guys and they had him in a building and it was a big,
a pretty big building,
like a pretty big but rectangular type building.
Five stories maybe.
Maybe it was four stories.
But anyways,
they had them,
they didn't have an a top floor,
but they had him in like the,
the floor below the top floor.
So he's the one on the third floor,
the fourth floor,
I forget.
But they have the guy in there,
and remember this is not,
there's no power in the city and it's,
the city is out in the middle of nowhere.
It's a fake city.
So you can hear everything right?
Kind of being pretty much here.
What's going on.
So they have our guy and they're like torturing him,
mock torturing him.
And of course they're up there.
Tell them like scream,
scream louder.
And he's yelling and yet you know that they're feeding him what to yell to try
and get us all riled up there.
There he's screaming,
they're going to kill me,
they're going to violate me screaming.
So they're having a good time with it.
And so our standard operating procedures was like,
Oh,
you know what?
Okay,
so there's a building needs to be cleared.
We go and we cleared the whole building.
We start on the ground floor.
We,
Claire,
every room that we call up to the next where we clear every room,
you go up to the next one.
And that means that there's not going to,
any bad guys that get get into your train,
there's not going to be any bad guys in between your force,
which can cause a blue on blue.
So when you're gonna clear every room,
let me,
you're gonna move down these hallways and you're gonna go from the bottom and
the top.
And that's just kind of the plan,
right?
Sort of normal.
And
like I said,
we,
we knew where they were,
so we immediately,
okay,
we had called the plant,
we have Craig could be their safe,
our guy,
we're all fired up.
And as we were,
we're doing this,
you know,
the,
the standard plan come up.
Like,
okay,
we'll go in this east door and we'll just clear the first floor.
And the second one,
when we get to know,
and as I'm sitting there kind of listening to this,
I s I just said,
hey,
no,
let's do this instead.
Let's just sneak up to the building because you can get to the building behind
other buildings.
You could find a little sneaky way to get there.
I'm like,
let's sneak him in the dead space.
Dead space is areas where the enemy can't see you or where you can't see the
enemy.
It's just areas where there's no v line of sight.
I said,
let's,
let's go.
And there was an external stairs,
like a fire escape on the outside of Warner.
I said,
let's go straight to the,
to the floor.
He's on,
won't clear any of the other floors but won't clear any of the rooms.
We'll just go right in the home,
go,
go directly to where he's at.
And that was the plan.
So we did it.
And um,
yeah,
and the thing was,
it was a,
it was,
we weren't,
that was kind of a new idea,
right?
Like,
Hey,
let's do this.
I'm not,
I know,
I believe me.
I'm not saying I'm the first guy that ever thought is,
I'm not,
I'm just saying our mindset at that moment was,
hey,
this is what we're being trained to do.
We'll do it.
We're trying to do so for anyone that's listening for any of my team guy
brothers that are like,
you didn't think,
I'm not saying I thought of it.
I'm saying at that moment in time we were focused on doing it one way and I said
Hell let's do something a little bit different.
And then once I said it everyone's like yeah,
yeah cause there was like everyone knew that was the right answer.
Right.
But you can just had to have that different look at it for a moment.
And so we did it.
We went to the extra mile stare when we went up really quiet.
Those,
the other thing we were like,
we're not going to say,
cause you know you're in a room,
you call it clear and you say next room and all this other stuff.
We weren't going to say anything.
We're just going to stay quiet.
So we went all the way up the stairs really quietly.
We walk in and we can hear him,
hear him yelling out the window like coma,
you better get him quick and all this stuff.
And then we go into the room cause silently and shoot all the op four in the
back.
We killed them all and we saved her hostage.
And there was one,
there was one seal cadre who we gave the,
and I'm not going to have his actual nickname,
but his nickname was along the lines of Simmie GME because simunition was with
simulation of what we used and semi Jimmy was really good at being a bad guy and
so,
and he would laugh at us,
you know,
we'd be moving through a building and you could hear him like if he shot you in
the neck and he'd be aiming for your neck or your nuts,
like he was going to get a good time with it and that's what you want.
You know,
you want your guys guard so send me Jimmy we,
but we got this moment with semi Jim.
He shot him in the back and they,
you know,
they were stoked,
they could see even though they want to win and they want to beat us,
but there's still stoked.
He wasn't cackling.
He was,
you know,
he was stoked on it.
And so they died.
We say we've got,
so my point in this is that
sometimes you have to do things that the enemy is not going to expect,
that people aren't gonna expect that your competitors not going to expect the
hard part about doing that.
It isn't actually doing the thing that they don't expect.
Right.
It's cause like I said other,
this is not what I,
what I said to do wasn't this,
you know,
miraculous Eureka moment of tactical genius.
It wasn't that this was anyone that would have taken a step back would have said
like that's a good call.
Let's do that instead.
But we were all wrapped up in that situation.
And so you want to learn how to do that.
You want to learn how to,
and again,
it's about detaching,
but a couple things that'll help you with that.
One is don't be the person that's planning everything.
Don't be the person.
And it's hard,
especially we talked about extreme ownership like,
and everyone wants to be a leader and they want to step up.
Don't try not to be the guy that comes up with every plan.
Literally try not to be that guy.
Now are there times when you're alone member where you want to like step up and
come with a plan?
Yeah.
I'm talking about when you're in an actual leadership position,
when you're a junior and you're,
you're trying to learn and you're trying to bring forth ideas.
Yeah man,
come up with some plans.
You know,
shoot that idea up cause you're throwing out good ideas that are going to get
bounced off the boss.
But when you're the guy that's in charge of trying not to be the guy that plans
everything,
try not to be the guy that makes every single call,
let the subordinate's plan or let the superiors plan.
Let other people come up with plans.
Now are there situations where like there's,
you've got to make calls.
Of course there are,
there's a dichotomy,
right?
But in that particular situation I didn't feel the need that I had to be the guy
that came up with a plan.
Like,
let other people do that and you know,
if someone else had come up with the,
come up with that standard plan and it was,
and I hadn't like detached,
I would've been like,
okay,
cool.
That's what we're doing,
where we're going forward.
You know?
But you,
you have to allow other people to come up with plans.
And the other thing is recognize that the,
the way that you know of doing something might not fit.
You might not know everything.
It's,
it's a good thing to always think to yourself.
You might not know everything,
right?
That's a good idea to have in your mind or is that what I know might not work.
That's something else.
What I know might not work.
That's another really smart thing to constantly replay in your head.
They what I know might not work.
Then you know,
so that that means you got to have an open mind then.
Then you've got to remember of course that rules.
Sometimes you have to break rules.
Okay?
You have to be very judicious when you decide you're going to break rules.
And there's some principals that that you cannot violate without massive,
okay
reason without a massively heavy reason and a way to mitigate the risks of
breaking whatever those fundamentals are like cover,
move,
like their cover move.
You should never violate cover move ever
except for when it just makes sense that you need to violate it.
So that,
and that story right there are kind of leads into the first question of Q and a,
which we haven't had Q and a Q and a in a while.
And the first question is,
uh,
we'll go ahead.
First question,
first question you raise,
you recently said Hackworth was a rule follower most of his career,
but in about face the book,
he always talks about how he went against his commanders rules.
How do you play the game but also act like Hackworth?
Yeah.
And so this is a classic example of the dichotomy leadership with regard to
obeying rules and,
and Hackworth absolutely obeyed the rules and he'll bathe them to the,
to the extreme.
Sometimes if you remember in the book,
He,
he,
he worked in situations where he,
they were like the strict dissed.
Yeah.
In garrison.
So like not in combat,
just in gears and he would,
everything's perfect uniform.
If you remember when General Mooky Amo was on and we talked to,
we talked to him about meeting hack for the first time and you know,
it's kind of like,
what was he like?
And he was like,
oh,
he was high and tight haircut,
totally square to wait.
That's following the rules to win Ti.
And the other thing that he played,
he definitely played the,
played the game.
Hmm.
Hackworth played the game he developed with,
he developed relationships with,
with people that were senior to him,
people that were influential.
Sla Marshall who he went on tour with,
if you remember through Vietnam and Sla Marshall,
he didn't really even respect but SLA Marshall had such big influence that he
said,
hey,
you know what,
how can it become Bros with this guy?
He played the game because Marshall had influence and he even took some hits,
you know,
took a little frag for,
for,
for SLA Marshall.
But at the same time,
if it's troops weren't getting the right treatment that he needed,
he would do what he needed to do.
He would break rules to take care of them if he had to.
And at the same time he would follow the rules to a t if you remember when he
took over the battalion in Vietnam,
the hopeless and wanted to turn them into the hardcore,
he brought all their crap into the middle of the thing and said,
we're going to fly it out of here.
No more radios,
no more guitars,
none of this other stuff and getting it out.
So that's following the rules to a t.
But at the same time,
if he needed to like steal food for them or steak,
something to get them,
he would do that stuff.
So he's constantly balancing that economy.
Another thing he did is he,
he took these administrative jobs that he hated
in order to rise through the ranks in order to become,
to get d,
Get places to develop relationships so we could have more influence.
He was assigned to the Pentagon.
He,
he,
in the book,
he talks about the Pentagon being working in the Pentagon being a claustrophobic
hole,
no more than 20 by 20 feet with 15 other people in it.
And he talks about Isaiah,
you'd say your paper,
your inbox would be filled when you showed up and you'd immediately,
the phone would be ringing.
He'd be talking to people all over the world via,
if all the people in Vietnam,
they're calling you or their their time zone.
And so he didn't like this job,
but guess what got the highest possible evaluations when he left.
Why?
Because he played the game
and he built these relationships with,
with all these kernels and all these generals and all these people that had
influenced his Glover,
Johns and Pearson and countless others by doing what he needed to do.
And then when he needed to,
he broke,
he broke the rules.
And sometimes he went a little too far with breaking the rules and
when he,
when he got out,
when they kind of drove him out after he did the big interview where he said,
hey,
we're not going to win.
They went and drilled down into his camps and looked at the things that he had
going on there,
said,
oh,
you'll yoga,
you're allowing this to happen and you're allowing this to happen.
So he left himself a little vulnerable by breaking the rules a little bit too
much.
So the a rule to learn from that,
it's like don't do things that people can hold over you.
And for me,
the things that people can hold over you are things where you can't stand up and
say,
yes,
that's what I did.
Yes,
Hey,
my guys didn't,
hadn't had a good meal in four weeks.
They've been in the field for three of those weeks and when they came out,
guess what?
I,
I figured out a way to get some steak and I took it from the rear and I had it
flown up using mill using our helicopters and I had a,
Yup,
that's what I did.
And if you want to,
you want to drop the hammer on me for that.
Got It.
Now if you do that,
that's cool,
but there's some things where you break the rules where maybe you wouldn't be
able to stand up tall and proud and say,
this is what I did in his why I did it.
So you want to be careful that you don't do things that will allow people to
hold things over your head.
And for me,
things that are things like that are things that you can't stand up with your
chest out and say,
this is what I did and this is why,
dude,
I know it wasn't within the regulations.
This is what I did.
This is why I do it.
And if I get fired because of that.
Understood.
Check.
Now here's where you get a little,
here's where we can,
we can
question hack for sure.
Let me ask you this.
If hack would have cause.
Okay.
So he,
he didn't play the game at the end.
He didn't play the game.
He went on an interview and said,
hey,
we're not going to win the war.
Not the way we're fighting.
We're not gonna win the war.
Within a few weeks,
he was driven out of the army.
He didn't play the game at that moment.
Right.
So let me ask you this.
If he would have played the game just a little bit,
just said,
look,
we need to change our strategy if we're,
you know what I mean?
If you were to just j and then he would have stayed in and then he would have
perhaps gotten a promotion and got perhaps gotten to a position where he
actually had influence over the way the war was being fought.
If he had done that,
would he have been better off?
Would he have been able to better help the situation?
Because I don't know,
once they drove him out,
it's not like that interview.
Well,
I don't know.
We'd have to check the check.
The historical sort of results of that interview.
It's certainly started to sway public opinion and maybe that,
you know,
maybe in his mind,
hey,
I need to tell everyone what's going on so we can get out of here.
Right.
So maybe,
maybe that was the intention.
Maybe that was the result.
Maybe that helped shut down the war eventually,
but maybe if he would have played,
continue to play the game,
he could have gotten to a position where he had more even more influence and
could change the way the war was being fought.
I don't know.
I'm sure we could have a long debate about that.
But that's as a leader,
something that you are going to have to weigh out all the time.
And there are situations where,
uh,
and actually breaking news today,
General Maddis just put in his resignation for being secretary defense.
So is,
that's a,
I'm,
we're going to have to talk about that when I get a little more information on
it.
Is that him saying,
look,
I,
it's going to be better for me to make this statement by leaving or would he
have been better off staying there where he can at least still have a massive
amount of influence because he's the secretary of defense will have to drill
down on that one.
That's a hmm.
That's a good question.
Both those are good questions.
And the bottom line is,
um,
if you haven't read about face,
read it and learn from a guy named Colonel David Hackworth.
Next question.
So the answer to that question was sort of another question,
kind of a question you gotta ask yourself.
Yes.
And that's a question and I've talked about this where if I tell you echo,
hey echo,
I want you to do this mission,
I want you to do it this way.
Take your platoon and go do it.
And you disagree with what I'm telling you.
And you just say,
hey boss,
I don't want to do it that way.
And I said,
hey,
you shut
up and do what I told you to do.
And you go,
you know what,
you can fire me.
But I'm not doing it.
I go,
okay,
fine,
you're fired and I get knucklehead over here who's a yes man.
It comes in and I tell them to go to the mission the way I told him to do it and
he goes and doesn't get to everyone killed.
Yeah.
Would it have been better off if you said,
okay boss,
I get it.
I,
I'll do it your way,
here's some things I'd really like to not do.
And you go,
no.
I said,
no,
shut up.
And then you take your guys,
you mitigate everything that you can.
Actually,
there's an example of this in band of brothers where major winners is being
told,
Hey,
send a reconnaissance element across the river again tonight and he doesn't want
to do it.
The the war's almost over.
They had taken some casualties I think the night before when they did the same
type of operation and he just says,
got it boss.
And then the guys go and they sit in the,
they pretend to go out,
but they really just sit in the basement of a building on their side of the
river.
And then later on they said,
Yup,
we went,
we came back,
we didn't find anything.
Okay,
cool.
There's a perfect example.
Imagine if if major winners,
Dick winters was like,
we're not doing it.
And now you're getting an ego contest with the colonel who was like,
Oh yes you are.
No,
we're not.
Okay,
fine.
You're fired.
Let me get knucklehead over here.
Who's gonna do what I told him to do?
Who's in total?
Yes,
man.
And now we take that risk and guys get killed.
So,
so who is it?
Dick winters played the game.
He played the game so he could still have that influence and power and,
and still protect his guys
can get complex.
Yeah.
It's very,
that's why leadership is hard.
It's,
it's weird though because when you say it's complex,
when you say leadership is hard at the same time,
like you,
if you're a principled human being and you have principles and you know what's
right and you're doing the right thing for the right reason,
the decisions are actually usually a little easier,
clearer,
clearer.
Yeah.
They might not be easy,
but they're clear.
Like,
I know what I'm supposed to do here.
I got it.
I,
I'm,
uh,
I'm going to figure this one out.
And this,
this I think applies to most scenarios where
like if you think of the big picture where if you're like,
hey,
I'm going to consider myself after everything's going to be said and done,
you know,
it kind of goes along with what you said.
Like,
oh,
can you still understand you?
If you consider,
okay,
look back,
you're going to,
cause there's gonna come a point where you're going to look back on this and
you're going to feel the way you're going to feel right now.
But later on,
how are you gonna feel about like how you handled it?
They don't know what decision you made in how you made a thing to tell kids too.
Would you,
if you're,
if you're at a party or you're wherever and something's going on,
would you be proud to stand up and be,
hey,
here's the situation and I,
this is what I did and this is why I did it.
If you can't,
maybe you should really reconsider what your actions are going to be.
No men,
it's because a lot of the times shoots where she was like kid as an adult to a
lot of the time it's like they're literally the opposite decision you like,
especially if it's
one of those like go along with the crowd kind of scenarios,
you know,
where it's like,
Oh hey,
it's easy to go longer and when you're a kid,
especially when it involves drinking and stuff,
sometimes there's,
there's really no consequence.
You know,
whatever.
You did something dumb.
No one gets hurt or dies or nothing like that.
But every once in a while there is,
but so it's like,
it makes it harder because you don't like when you go do something,
I don't know.
Dumb.
Go jump off a bridge.
I don't know,
something to drink and drive or whatever and no one dies or no one,
nothing big happens.
It sort of reinforces that maybe it might be okay,
you know,
you maybe be able to slide with this behavior a little bit,
but at the end of the day,
you know?
Yeah.
If you can clearly see that big picture where in the future you're going to be
looking back on how you handled it.
Yeah.
Here's another thing,
same concept I used to tell,
I told my guys was you just might as well act like CNN is recording what you're
doing and it's good,
right?
You want to act like an idiot,
guess what?
It's going to be on scene and because someone's got a camera somewhere around
there and you might as well be saying that today as a kid,
as a teenager,
you might as well be saying,
Yup,
this is,
this is the next viral video.
This is my 15 minutes of fame is going to be me doing whatever I'm doing right
here.
So it's got to watch out for that.
Learn from hack.
Next question.
Doco I struggle with receiving banter from other guys.
Banter.
Okay.
I'm naturally a sensitive gut which lends myself to take normal smack talk from
other guys personally,
I'm trying to get after it.
I wake up early,
I work out,
eat healthy,
work pretty hard,
but still seemed out some deep seated insecurities which flare up when guys
keeping me stick.
I have some bloody good mates and I want to get to the point where I can take
smack talk for what it is and even give a bit of stick back to the guys.
What can I do to help this?
Here's one thing that you can try to get into your brain and this is one of
those things that's hard to get into your brain and it's even harder to actually
get it in your brain and functionally use this thought.
Here's the thought.
Okay?
The more,
okay,
if you're,
if you're paranoid about something,
if you're insecure about something,
the more you let things bother you,
the more insecure you will appear.
Well,
let me say that again.
The more you let things bother you,
the more insecure you are going to appear.
And the worse whatever that thing that you're worried about,
whatever that thing that makes you feel insecure,
the worst it's going to appear to everyone else.
So if you got a big nose and you're embarrassed because you got a big nose,
and every time someone says something about your big nose,
you get mad and you get offended,
that big nose it be close,
even bigger.
So think about that.
If there's something that bothers you and you let it be known
and you let it bother you,
divorce,
it's going to get.
And,
and also think about this.
Another thing that will help,
these are things I'm trying to help help,
uh,
sort of smooth the edges of insecurity.
Here's another one.
People,
even though you think even when you think they are,
and it's kind of egotistical to think this,
but we all do it.
People aren't sitting around and thinking about you and your weaknesses.
They're not sitting around and thinking about you and your weaknesses.
They're not like,
that's your ego telling you that.
So
don't sit there and think everyone's looking at your big nose all the time.
They don't care.
They've got their other problems.
They got their own life going on you.
They don't care about your big nose.
You know what makes them care about it when they know,
if they say something to you,
it bothers you.
That's the first thing you're going to think when they see you again.
Here comes the good time,
some fun.
Now it,
and here's another thing.
If you want to kind of mitigate that man,
do what I do it.
Mark doesn't weigh the warrior kid when Uncle Jake says,
hey,
if you're getting made fun off,
he's in in way the word could call them plate face San Marco,
you got to route this Guy Nathan James had telemark.
Oh you got a round face,
you look like played.
Calls him plate face.
That's his insult as insults him all the time and it bothers him cause he's
looking in the mirror going right.
I feel I look like a plane.
Let's,
it bothered him and uncle Jake says,
hey,
go,
go make fun of yourself.
And he finally gets a chance.
He does,
uh,
they're,
you know,
a class and they have to do a self portrait and he draws himself as a plate,
a plate face.
And when the kid that's been making fun of it,
sees it,
he laughs and then guess what does make fun of him anymore about it because he
realizes it doesn't bother and they kind of bond a little bit and they kind of
bonded a little bit actually what he's going for in this question that is,
yeah.
Yeah.
So you got them and it's,
it's this,
that's why I said it's hard to do this because when you're insecure about and
your big nose or you're insecure about your big years or whenever,
and you let people know that,
or maybe you just think it's in your brain and you think if you say something,
let's get even worse.
It won't get worse.
Might get worse for an uptick for a second.
Right?
It might,
you make fun of yourself,
you know,
people are like,
oh yeah,
that's right.
I didn't notice that you do it.
Then it'll kind of,
no one really cares.
And that's why in the teams and the teams,
you never let anyone know that something bothers you or if they know it bothers
you,
you're going to hear about it forever.
That's just going to be how,
that's just,
that's just the way it's going to be.
And what that means,
the polar opposite of that or the flip side of that is it's not fun to harass
some,
it's not fun to harass someone about something that doesn't bother them.
It's not even fun.
Right.
It's not fun.
Why would you harass someone when they don't get it?
When you don't even get a rise out of him?
He's just not fun.
You just leave that thing.
You look for something else.
Yeah.
So poke a little fun at yourself.
These guys are going to back off because they're bored.
If you show no reaction and like you said that that kind of self deprecating
humor will formed a little bond.
Yeah.
You can uh,
give a little stick back to the guys.
If you start giving stick the guys be ready to take it back though.
Yeah,
they're going to escalate.
Yeah.
That's just so,
I mean,
I grew up with two brothers,
one twin brother,
and that's like a,
like that's literally the foundation of our relationship is just you tease the
other guy about some lit,
everything.
Like he can come in with a new shirt on that's a seal platoon.
Yeah.
Like,
oh,
we'll be like,
you know,
like breath,
not even something to tease somewhere they sell men's shirts where you bought
that.
Yeah.
Whenever it's lear that's,
it's so bad to the point where one,
um,
when,
when I got with my current life,
when we were,
when we started dating or whatever,
like it's just habit,
you know,
like even you like same thing,
like you'll,
you'll give me crap,
I'll give you kind of whatever.
But it's so common that I do it to her.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And you know,
at first she's like,
Oh,
what?
Like what,
why are you teasing me so much?
Like your,
cause I knew where even before we were together,
I knew her for gears actually.
And he was like,
Hey,
I kind of annoying,
you know,
he's like teases or whatever.
And I had to like reel it back yourself.
Yeah,
because that,
because that is so,
so much of how guys do it,
you know,
100% right.
And I've told this story before when I got,
when I was going to college,
I was around team guys all day and I started doing the team guy thing with my
wife and after,
yeah.
She's like,
Hey,
I'm not in the teams so you can be quiet now.
And I was like,
wow,
she's right.
And I didn't even realize it because that's just,
you know,
all day long you show up,
you show up in the platoon space and his verbal sparring.
Yes.
As soon as you walk through the door he's going to say something,
they're going to bring it.
And what's interesting is how he's,
how he's like,
I want to get to the point where you know,
he,
he can speak to her with,
the thing is,
I would agree with this.
I'll probably even hundred 10% which is hard to agree 100% but I feel this way,
it's probably stronger than him.
Like you ever been around someone who like you just can't really joke around
with like,
I'm not,
I'm not the kind guy who all tease someone and try to like to make them,
you know,
especially if,
I don't know I'm good or whatever,
but um,
but if you're around someone who can't really take it,
you can't joke around with them.
It's like,
man,
I don't want that guy to be there,
man.
I wish he just wasn't,
you know,
I'm not mad at him,
but I just,
I don't want to hang around with that guy.
You don't want to be that guy.
So even if like,
especially at first,
like let's say,
okay,
I'm,
I'm this guy right here.
The worst is someone that can dish it out but can't take it.
But what do you mean?
Yeah,
that is the worst.
I don't,
the only reason I wouldn't say he's the worst is what's worse than that.
If he's dishing it out and he can't take it,
it's kind of,
you get a payoff of teasing the guy.
I'm saying it.
Let's say he doesn't do shit up.
Let's say he's just a guy you just can't joke around with.
It's like,
man,
you're making me uncomfortable kind of thing,
you know.
But if this guy cause you to your point,
if it's,
yeah,
if it is annoying when people can't take it and you make a joke and they get all
fired up and they,
and then they're like actually mad,
right?
Yeah,
that's,
that's well that's how you end up with people that aren't really your friends.
That's exactly right.
So yes.
Yes.
So you get there man.
I say get there and at first just,
and you kind of made it really clear to me how,
you know,
when you make a change or something,
it's not going to whoop boom,
you're off to the races with the change going full speed,
low drag,
high speed.
It's not going to be like that reddit for,
especially with this kind of stuff,
if you,
if you already know you're insecure,
which is a big step ahead by the way.
Some people it or I'm not insecure and meanwhile they're getting it,
they know it,
but they just don't admit it.
Yeah.
So this guy,
he knows so,
but you're gonna feel it man.
When they call you be,
you know,
whatever they're calling you,
whatever.
You're going to sort of feel it on the inside still,
but just don't behave,
you know,
in a way just be like,
Oh,
I dunno,
I dunno what to do.
There's plenty of things to do.
But yeah,
I mean you do want to get there.
Hundred percent check.
Next question,
jock.
Tell me three,
sorry.
How do you deal with ultimatums from customers,
bosses,
et Cetera,
that are unrealistic due to the nature of the situation and the ultimatum.
What am I to do with ultimatums is I am going to tell the truth
about the situation to them,
but first I'm going to tell the truth about the situation to myself because you
got to look at the situation and say to yourself,
is this truly unattainable,
like truly unattainable and,
and sometimes even though it seems truly unattainable,
but then when you actually think about it,
you realize,
oh,
I could attain this.
I can make this happen.
I'm going to have to sacrifice whatever to make it happen.
I'm going to have two to co,
it's going to cost me or the team or the company something in order to make an
APP.
Like,
Oh,
you want that done,
or you want that,
you want that project done by the 15th cool.
We'll get it done.
Uh,
but here's what we're not gonna be able to do,
or here's what I'm not going to be able to do.
And I'm also gonna make sure that I pressure test the ultimatum against me
giving the absolute full measure of effort,
right?
Like,
wow,
if I go 110% right,
not even honored percent beyond,
you're going to give it everything you can.
Is it achievable?
Because a lot of times people will do,
it's an old community,
can't make it.
Well,
as a member of a team,
I want people's attitude to be like,
you know what?
We're gonna do it.
We're going to get it done.
No one else would be able to do this,
but we're going to do it.
Watch.
That's,
I like saying that sometimes watch,
watch.
I used to say,
watch me work.
Yeah.
Where I got it from some really,
so then,
okay,
so now you truly,
you tell yourself the truth about the situation.
You figure out that there's truly under no circumstances that this is possible.
Then it's my time to tell them the truth,
which is like listen and I'll get my data together,
I'll get my information together,
I'll explain to them what,
you know,
what,
why I can't,
I'm not going to be able to physically get this done.
It's physically not possible and then you know what the shortfalls are going to
be.
Now I once I explained that to them,
if they're,
if they're completely unwavering,
cause if you explain everything and you put your data together and you say,
look,
the bottom line is to d two to assemble this many pieces by our best to people
on the team,
they'd take some on outreach and you want us to assemble 14 of them in three
hours.
It is not possible for us to do that
in.
Even if you gave me more people,
it doesn't matter if they didn't know how to do that.
So it can't be done.
I need at least whatever,
six hours with those,
but whatever,
whatever it is.
If they're unwilling to to waiver on the ultimatum at all,
like no,
go.
You need to get it done.
You need to get done.
Well then what I'm gonna do,
okay,
I'm going to try my hardest.
I'm going to buckle down,
I'm gonna do my best.
I'm going to see how much,
how close I can get to achieving the goal.
I'm going to have fun.
I'm going to go so hard that it's going to get nuts,
like we're going to get it done.
And then when,
if we fall short,
which we will,
because I figured out there's no physical humanly possible way to make this
happen,
then what I'm do is I will go to them and I'll explain the things that I am
going to do differently next time in order to meet their goals.
Right?
I want to say,
listen,
you know what,
I,
I should have asked you earlier if this was a possible thing and I should have
had a backup plan.
So here's what I'm putting into place now to make sure this doesn't happen
again.
Or Hey,
I am going to need more manpower so that if we run into this again,
I've got the people,
it's my fault for not staffing us up correctly or I need to pay more attention
to what's happening in the future so that I can have a better aware,
I have better awareness of when this type of situation will unfold so I can have
my team prepared for it or these complexities that happened.
I didn't explain to them.
I didn't explain them to you well enough.
And so if you understood,
if I do a better job of making you understand the difficulties of making this
happen,
hopefully you'll realize that there's more time is needed.
So I'm not going to go in there and throw up my arms and see you.
I told you so you were stupid.
I was right.
Because then that's just sabotage to now.
They don't believe you anyways.
Now when you say,
well,
we couldn't get it done.
See,
like I told you,
I told you we,
we need more time.
And they're like,
yeah,
of course you,
you know,
you,
you went into it thinking you're gonna fail.
And guess what?
The self fulfilling
prophecies.
Good job.
Yeah.
You proved yourself to be right.
Loser,
demoted.
And that's what I do up and down the chain.
By the way,
you know,
ultimatums can come up and down the chain of command,
hold a line,
do your best.
That's what you do.
Yeah.
That seems,
and tell the truth of it all starts with telling the truth to yourself and then
to your people that you're charged customer,
you know,
client,
I want this foundation poured by such and such a date.
Hey Week we will do our best.
Here's the shortfalls,
you know,
whatever.
That's the way it is.
Yeah.
And that's a big one.
They're like,
where I kind of learned this from you,
where it's the cause you can like t to tell you like,
oh hey,
I can't,
this can't be done.
Like he kind of,
you get to the point in your mind where you're like,
we both know it can be done,
but it does,
you know,
given my current risk and sleep schedule and you know,
I got this chill,
I like to watch it.
That'll kind of,
you know,
it's like that kind of situation.
I don't want to miss that.
So it,
it,
it kind of shapes up to be like that,
you know?
Whereas like for sure we both know and I don't know,
you know,
like if there's a boss who's like just grinding someone into the ground.
Okay.
That's a whole different scenario.
But yeah,
at the end of the day,
like if you're truthful and it was like,
Hey,
get this done or you're fired kind of thing.
And then you start with the truth that you say,
it'd be like,
can I get it done?
And then you really think,
let's say like you were going to die.
I didn't know you could get it done a lot of the time.
I'm not saying all the time.
Of course,
of course.
The amount of times in my naval career,
let's call it when I was in the navy,
that guys said to me like,
we can't do it.
I can't even remember times like,
cause guys were the guys just like damn.
Like I know.
Yeah.
They wouldn't be like,
well I don't know Jocko.
I'd be like,
hey look,
here's what we've got to get done.
Yeah,
I think we can do it.
And they'd be like,
Yup,
cause we're about to go get some.
But yeah,
man,
you know,
obviously the situation,
some situations are more like more serious,
you know,
like you're not going to,
I don't know for sure.
But yeah,
that telling the truth thing tell the truth.
I do speak from a position of luxury where I have the truth reflected at me
pretty accurately on a pretty regular basis.
So I'm not saying it's that easy to tell the truth,
but if you just try hard try January,
you've got to be genuine,
right?
Genuinely be like,
yes,
this is true about myself.
Do it.
Check.
Next question.
Question for the next podcast.
Is your wife disciplined?
How do you navigate a potential mismatch between you two?
What about when family non disciplined costs you unexpected time and energy
taking from your goals?
Family nondisciplinary what?
Like my
family's not being disciplined.
Yeah.
Not on board or whatever.
They're not on board with the program.
My wife is,
she runs a tight ship and is disciplined in a little bit of a different way than
me.
Then she's not the same as me.
And if that were to cause some kind of a conflict between us,
we'll then,
that's my fault for not communicating with her and allowing her to understand my
perspective and understanding her perspective.
So for instance,
what are,
what's the situation,
right?
Oh my wife wants me,
you know,
she wants to spend time with me in the morning,
whatever.
Right.
When you do wake up early and workout before she's awake,
you're working out.
It's not her fault.
It's my fault.
Well,
what about when,
oh,
I really want to eat dinner with you at night.
Okay,
cool.
I'll eat dinner with you and I'll stay up later at night so that I can get my
work done and that's fine.
You go to bed,
that's not,
that's not my response.
That that's not your responsibility.
That's my responsibility.
It's not your responsibility to mold your life around my whole life.
Right.
That's not,
that's,
that's not the way it is.
And by the way,
when the family is doing something that is taken away,
what did you say?
My energy taken away my energy and taking away my time.
Then I fixed that problem.
And when I say that I fixed the problem,
I don't mean I fix them.
I don't mean that I impose my discipline on them.
I'm,
it might involve some adjustments or some attempts to get adjustments,
but I'm not be just really simple.
I don't blame my family when things don't go right.
I couldn't work out today because my kid was sick.
My daughter spilled the milk and I was like,
Hey,
this is the same.
This is just about ownership.
Like if you just want to blame your family when you're weak or you make a
mistake or you didn't organize or you didn't explain to people correctly,
then that's the way it is.
I can say this to your family is not you.
Your family is not you.
They aren't on your program.
That's not there.
That's not their deal.
Hey,
if they're on it,
great.
That's cool.
My family's not all on my program.
That's not the way it works.
You Impose,
oh,
that's fun.
There was,
where's that kitchen?
You?
Oh,
you want to,
you want to impose your program on everyone in your family.
What are they going to do?
What?
It's the same thing that happens with any team.
If you start imposing your strict discipline on them,
cool.
You can get them to do what you want him to do at that moment.
Guess what they do?
As soon as they get the opportunity to rebel against you,
they rebel.
You get a mutiny.
You get a kid that's rebellious beyond the norm that's doing thing that's
actually gonna going to really reject you,
so you got to,
you don't blame your family.
Fix the problem.
Do you know who you have control over?
You?
You don't have control.
You don't have control over your nine year old kid.
You might think you do,
but you don't.
You got to make,
you don't have control over your wife to just make her,
you know,
get in the game.
Oh,
you want to,
you want to stay on the program,
you want to cook,
uh,
whatever.
14 chicken breasts on a Sunday night.
So you've got two a day during the week,
honey,
make it happen.
No honey,
don't make that happen.
If you are a good leader and you explain what your goals are and you get her on
board with the program,
then yeah,
guess what she's doing on Sunday night helping you cook some chicken breasts for
the week.
Yeah,
but this is just like anything else,
man.
This is just like any other leadership situation.
You want to blame the team when something's going wrong that's not going to get
you a solution.
You need to take ownership of the problem.
You need to get the problem solved.
And when I say get the problem solved you,
this doesn't mean impose your will on the team.
That means you need to lead the team and there's a big difference.
So
get some,
yeah.
Yeah I can do.
And by the way,
the better.
Just like anything else,
just like Hackworth,
the better relationship that you build with your wife and with your kids,
guess what?
The more flexibility you have,
the more leeway they give you.
The worse relationship you build with your wife and kids,
the less flexible and the less leeway and the less chicken breasts you're going
to have cook for you.
It's true.
They're not in the game with you.
Yeah.
So build a relationship.
I know that might sound like like,
oh well we're married so we have relationship,
not necessarily true.
Build a relationship.
Make them understand where you're coming from.
Make them understand what the strategic goals are.
Yeah.
Make them understand.
Just like in a leadership situation,
make sure they understand how the strategic goals that you're trying to achieve
for yourself will then come all the way back down and impact them in a positive
way.
Cause by the way,
if you're doing things strategically,
are gonna help you that are going to screw over the rest of the team or in this
case family.
Guess what?
You're not going to get support for those goals because they're not helping out
the team.
If you're doing it for yourself and yourself only that's problematic.
So if you're,
hey,
I want to work out,
I want to get,
you know,
I want to work out,
I want to train Jujitsu every day.
Okay,
well how do I benefit from that,
honey?
Okay,
well let me tell you how.
Here's my plant in six years,
I,
you know,
I'm a purple belt right now it's six years.
I'm going to get my black belt and when I get my black belt,
we're going to open a school and when I opened a school,
guess what we're going to do all day?
We're going to teach Jiu Jitsu.
We're going hang out at our gym.
We're going to have a good time.
That's a strategic goal.
I need you in the game with me right now.
That's totally different than a droid.
Yup.
I'm a man.
Yeah.
Don't keep me,
keep me from this.
Well,
yeah,
in that too,
depending on who you are,
obviously,
but I would even say that's even just speaking from my own experience,
that's even over saying it really.
Like,
let's say you take Jujitsu or working out or whatever,
you know,
to do that,
but I get it.
I get the example for sure.
No,
you're using something much more simple,
easier way more bay and just say,
Hey,
this,
this part of my life.
Even if it's new,
it's a new,
I know our family's chaotic.
You need my help with the kids and be like,
but hey,
this,
this sort of,
this means a lot to me and it makes me feel good.
Makes me,
you know,
a happy person or whatever.
It can mean you can.
We make this work,
you know,
candle can,
we does what?
Do you know how you like this other thing?
Sure.
Yeah.
I want to support you doing that.
Here's where I need support,
right?
Yeah.
Just think,
puts a smile on my face.
Yeah.
You want me smiling around here?
That's what,
and people,
I'm sure someone's going to bring up the fact that there were times when I was
in the dirt and I would come home from work at seven 30 at night,
I'd pick up my gym bag,
I drop off my my work bag,
and I just walk.
I'd go,
Oh,
hang on,
I'm going to train.
And there was a few times where she did not want me to go train tears in her
eyes.
You gotta be kidding me.
You've been gone all week.
You've been gone for two weeks.
You come home at seven 30 and you're going to go train instead of eating dinner
with us.
I was like,
Yep.
The reason I bring that up,
because I know someone's gonna bring up,
that's not good leadership.
That's not me being cool.
That's not me building the relationship.
That's me moving in the other direction.
Yeah.
So that's not what I'm saying to do,
but if you come home,
hey look,
here's the deal.
Here's what's going on.
Here's why I,
you know what I've got?
I'd come home from work.
I got a lot of stuff in my brain.
I'm in a bad mood when I come home and I don't want to be in a bad mood around,
you don't want to be a bad mood around the kids.
I'm going to go train for an hour.
When I come back,
I'm gonna have a smile on my face.
Watch
what?
Boom man,
like,
and,
and that's actually my wife eventually told me like,
oh,
when you don't train,
you're not nice to be around.
Not that I was intentionally going on and you get to try it.
No,
but you just have the,
uh,
you don't,
you don't have that release.
That is a real thing for sure.
I mean it's manageable.
Everyone's different I think,
obviously,
but I wouldn't,
you can even say something even more,
cause that's a hard one to,
to sell sometimes to some people to be like,
hey,
all be happier,
you know?
Then they'll be like,
well or except for that all be happier.
Maine's,
we'll be happier.
Yeah.
And you got to,
you're right though.
You got to,
you got to give and take.
Right.
You've got to say,
okay,
what do you,
what can I do for you?
Exactly right.
That's,
that's what it is.
Be like,
Hey,
this means a lot to me.
You know,
to,
and usually,
you know,
in a relationship like that,
they care if something means something to your husband and wife or whatever.
Like that's not nothing.
That's something,
you know,
look,
if you,
if the,
if you're a husband and you say this,
you,
it means a lot to me.
Therefore you need to sacrifice your whole thing to accommodate it.
You can do that,
but it's not nothing.
So you can say,
hey,
as a leader you can't have the team sacrifice everything thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
Through I do a good job on this mission,
I'm going to get promoted,
you know,
or hey,
if we do a good job with this product,
I'm going to make more money.
Bottom line,
it's more from my bottom line profitability for our shareholders.
No one cares.
The front line doesn't care about profitability for their shareholders unless
they understand how it relates back to them.
Yeah.
So family doesn't care about you train in Jujitsu unless they realize how it's
going to come back to you.
So what you do is you tell her like,
hey,
can we make this work?
And actually whatever,
however this gets in the way of us,
you know,
like whatever.
Like I want to just in general make that up to some way,
you know,
like what can,
what can I do for you?
Like I said,
or,
or what do you want to do something or let's,
let's do this so we can both kind of have something fun.
Come with me if you want,
but hey,
don't,
don't just automatically expect your wife to love Jujitsu.
Like,
yeah,
I'd love to do too.
Unfortunately,
unfortunately goes for everyone.
Even though most it's possible.
It's very possible.
Yeah.
But I'm saying,
you know,
if like how you're saying like make it make,
you got to accommodate it,
you know,
certainly if you're doing like a workout,
it let's say,
and it's your thing,
right?
Okay,
look dope,
work out,
you know,
and that's my thing.
Whatever do you get to I think is a different one because working out is like,
you can kind of do that whenever.
But Jujitsu is like,
if you don't be,
you got to go train with some people.
Yeah.
You know?
So yeah man,
if in constant communication too,
by the way,
like you,
you know,
cause after a while it's like,
how are you going to do two again?
And you're like done.
And the kids kind of need help with the homework and I'm swamped with this other
family stuff,
you know,
kind of thing.
But if you're constantly communicating and then she'll tell you,
hey,
do you mind not going on this day because of this?
And you're like,
okay,
me going on this specific day,
is that more important than the help that they need with the homework?
You know?
And you can accurately kind of navigate your way through your,
your new situation,
you know?
But yeah,
you gotta keep talking on that one because some people they think,
oh,
I can go,
do you get to know?
And I don't have to say nothing about,
I'm just rolling out under every circle.
You know?
It doesn't work like that sometimes.
Don't,
don't be like me and don't be like Taco.
Well,
my wife is very understanding.
Yeah.
So that's great.
Sure.
Yeah.
My wife probably would have murdered me,
rightfully so,
like killed me as a crime.
Next question,
we'd love to hear your thoughts on the deck economy of honest self expression
versus normal face and or passion versus discipline.
Uh,
if you aren't caught up on all the podcasts,
normal faces that came,
I used to play with my kids where they would have to keep an expressionless face
or what I called the normal face.
Good game by the way.
And you,
I would line up my kids and they would have to keep that face and then if they
change their expression anyway,
I would hit them in the head with a,
with the inside cardboard role of a thing of wrapping paper and or I had
eventually made like foam pieces for it cause they were a little bit more
durable and,
and you could hit really hard and it wouldn't hurt it at all.
So anyways,
I know it sounds like you should call child services on me,
but it's fun game to play because as you hit one kid that makes the other kids
laugh and then you end up hitting them all and everyone was laughing and it's
fun.
So,
and there's also a pragmatic reason to do it because it teaches people to
control their emotions and there are times,
there are many times where you have to learn to control your emotions.
And as kids,
if you learn to control your emotions,
it's going to be beneficial for you in many ways.
But does that mean that you should keep a normal face all the time?
Never show emotions.
No.
It's not like that at all.
There's like everything else.
There's a dichotomy that you have to balance.
If your kid wins a wrestling match,
you should be happy and great and smiling.
Yeah,
high five.
Right.
That's cool.
If you bite
into a amazing piece of prime rib that your wife cooked for you,
then you should raise your fist in the air and say,
yes,
my wife,
the first time she ever cooked primary,
she,
we didn't know this,
but she has a talent.
She,
you know,
she cooks dry chicken prime rib.
She knocks it out of the park.
First time she ever cooked prime rib.
And I took my,
I smelled amazing.
I was like,
Oh,
this is,
I took my first bite.
I looked at her and I looked up at her and I said,
I want to revamp,
redo our vows from marriage,
renewed the value,
renew the vows.
So yes,
um,
you know,
scenarios like that.
Yeah.
You want to show your emotions and if here's something,
if your team slacks off
and if you fail the mission,
you fail the task.
Of course you're going to own it.
But you might,
you know,
you might want to show a little anger about what happened so that everyone knows
like,
oh,
who's chocolate is normally get mad and he's mad.
And so we really did something bad.
And,
and you know,
even though you're blaming herself,
like I can't believe like this down.
You know what I mean?
Like your show a little bit that people go,
okay,
so there going to show some.
Most you,
if you get bad and well if you give them news that that you know you got a
friend that died,
we know that's,
you got to let those emotions out.
There's all kinds of situations where emotions are not only acceptable but
they're needed and they're required to.
And in fact,
if you don't have emotions in those situations,
that's horrible.
You need to have them not only as a person,
as a human being,
you need to let out your emotions sometimes.
But as a leader,
if you don't show any emotions at all,
no one's going to follow you.
There's no connection between you and the people on your team that if you ever,
if you just sit there and think about people that you've worked for that didn't
have show emotions.
Yeah,
no connection with them.
You don't care about them,
you'll leave.
You won't go the extra mile to get the job done.
So you have to show emotions.
Of course,
there are many times in life in the world where showing your emotions are going
to have a negative impact on your situation.
Your [inaudible].
You give up the takedown in a Jujitsu competition and you show it in your face.
That person just thinks I just broke.
Do you want to show any emotion?
Their boss tells you you're getting stuck with the underperforming team.
Show any emotion,
right?
Don't,
don't.
Oh Man,
don't do that,
but hey,
what about this?
There's a good one.
Boss is giving you feedback that you don't agree with.
Roll your eyes.
You know what I mean?
The the heavy side,
the clenched teeth.
As you're trying to listen with this person,
you don't even respect him.
He's telling us,
what's that going to get you?
I'm not going to get you anything.
Then showing that negative emotion there,
you need to keep normal face and that situation,
your kids doing something that's annoying.
It's trying to test your patients and they're just trying to piss you off.
Don't let them keep it in check.
Get told to go to the other line in DMV after you've been waiting for an hour in
one.
Don't freak out.
Don't show any emotions.
Got It.
Here's,
here's another one.
We already talked about this one,
your friends or poke in front of you because you missed a shot at the range or
you got lost on a land navigation course or whatever.
Get All mad.
Don't get frustrated.
Don't show any emotion.
You know,
they make fun of your hair cut.
They make fun of your accent.
They make fun of whatever.
Don't show emotions.
Don't freak out.
That's the other balance.
Now,
there are also times where you might have to force yourself to show some emotion
just to get the point across,
right?
Your kid hasn't listened to you after five or six violations.
You might have to show some anger or they or they do something that's going to
get them hurt,
right?
You got to show some emotions so that they realize that was real.
But flying off the temporary flying off the handle and losing your temper is
almost never does you any good.
So yeah,
you have to be balanced.
In order to be balanced,
you have to be in control and an order being control,
you have to detach from your emotions so you can control your emotions and not
let your emotions control you.
Yup.
I think we already talked about this one part before.
We're like,
you know,
like with your kids or whatever and you're,
you fly off the handle,
not fly off the handle,
but you,
you show emotion,
you raise your voice
and yell at them because this one is important.
This lesson that I'm teaching that you obviously didn't get it before.
What is your thing?
You can't do that every single time.
Of course,
you know,
every single lesson like,
okay,
oh,
it was effective when it reasonably priced.
Let me just raise my voice now.
Right.
Logically limb die if that,
if that is what induces their compliance,
let me just do that.
Right.
It doesn't work that way because after a while I like,
oh Brad Talk.
Just don't noise.
Yeah,
no.
So yeah,
you got to be like,
Yay.
Yeah.
Or yeah,
just be like normal face,
north face,
north face.
Everything you know and then like the one time you use it it's like the,
what do you call the,
there's this video gave me used to play.
It's like you could just press the button and
blow up everybody.
Anyway,
long story but yeah,
don't use it all the time is what I'm saying.
Just use it like sparingly.
Zane.
Yeah,
judiciously.
Cool.
That's good.
I do know what you're saying.
Next question.
I'm in college and I'm working towards going to ocs after I graduate.
I work a food service job.
I was trying to teach a 17 year old at work why she shouldn't half ass cleaning
a fryer.
I said because of unmitigated daily discipline in all things.
That includes cleaning the fire.
It still didn't quite get it.
I didn't say to her that I make the,
I make the fryer spotless because if I can't manage to clean the fire,
how can expect myself to lead people in the military ipso facto war because I
didn't think that,
I didn't think that was appropriate to say to that 17 year old girl.
I try to lead by example,
but I'm not sure that is enough.
How can I best explain or show my younger coworkers why they should have unmade
mitigated daily discipline in all things when she,
when the stakes are only a fryer and not lives.
Okay.
Let's see.
This is where degree.
Wait,
we're kind of in the same vein on some stuff tonight,
which is good,
right?
It's good.
First of all,
because unmitigated daily discipline and all things should be first and foremost
applied to you.
Not,
not everyone else around you.
Let's start with yourself.
Imposing discipline on other people is not leadership.
It's just an offer.
Authoritarian person barking orders.
Um,
so to answer your question,
well first of all,
read,
if you haven't read the book,
the Dichotomy of leadership,
you might want to check that one out.
There's a couple chapters you could focus on.
One of them is called resolute,
but not overbearing.
One of them's called disciplined but not rigid.
One of them's called hold people accountable,
but don't hold their hands.
And this is pretty much why we had to write the dichotomy of leadership because
you're out there,
good on you trying to take extreme ownership
and that's great,
but you're not,
you're not paying attention to the dichotomy of leadership.
So let,
let me,
let me break it down for you a little bit more clearly and then you can go read
the book as well,
which will help you.
You say that the stakes are only a clean fryer and not lives
and you're right,
lives are not at stake and neither really is the functionality of the franchisor
itself because it doesn't have to be completely spotless.
And in fact,
if you're trying to keep it completely spotless,
it might actually waste time that she could be doing something that's more
important like prepping the potatoes or washing her hands to keep the food
sanitary.
So you need to think about that.
How truly important.
Like when you say on me when I say,
because I say this all the time and I apologize for throwing you a little bit
too far in one direction.
Unmitigated daily discipline in all things.
There's no,
there's no departure from that.
You're like,
right.
That's what it is.
There's no departure for that.
But here's the deal.
If you were in the military and you got spun up about little things that don't
really matter,
you are wasting your leadership capital.
And when something is actually important,
it's what you were just talking about,
Echo.
When something actually important comes up,
your troops aren't even gonna listen to you because they don't know what
anything.
Well,
they don't know what's important and what's not.
Because you say that everything is important.
Like,
hey,
why do I need to stay on watch?
Why do I need to stay awake during watch?
That's not any more important to you than whether I have,
uh,
a stain on my shirt because you're freaking out about everything.
So,
so who,
how do I know what's what?
Now here's the deal.
You can go too far in the other direction and you can let people do whatever
they want and it can completely lacked discipline.
And the little things do matter.
The little things do matter.
But you gotta remember they only met her a little.
And if you waste your time and you waste your leadership and your waste,
your energy on things that don't matter or things that matter very little,
then you won't be able to lead your team when it really counts.
What happens is it's a slip,
it's a slope,
it's a,
it's a slippery slope and if you let some things slide,
then you let something else side,
then you let something outside.
Eventually you've got no discipline.
So you have to be careful of that.
But at the same time,
it's the other direction.
What you end up in,
in the other direction.
If you,
if you impose on mitigated daily discipline in all things,
you're going to end up like,
um,
here's a movie reference Echo Charles Animal House.
Sure.
Have you seen it?
Yells Young?
No.
Okay,
so you don't remember Niedermeyer neater,
the ROTC guy that just yell like it.
Every wall,
you're worthless and weak.
He's like that.
He's a guy that's just barking and going crazy.
And that's a comical example.
But I'll tell you what,
you want a example,
a real,
a real good example that you can check out once again,
go and watch the first episode of the band of brothers series and checkout.
Captain saw Belle,
okay.
The company commander of Easy Company,
he is hardcore and he has,
he imposes absolute unmitigated discipline in all things on his whole company.
He holds the line.
Oh,
dirty weapon.
No,
no liberty for you.
Pass,
revoked,
rust on your knife,
past revoked,
uniform out of uniform creases in your boots,
your creases in your pants pass revoked.
Oh,
that guy's doing it.
He's doing that on mitigated discipline in all things.
And guess what happens to him?
He gets fired.
His troops hate him.
He's worried about things that don't matter.
Dick winters,
totally squared away worries about things that are important.
Hmm.
And as a individual,
and if you remember,
I don't even know if they showed us,
and men are brothers,
but as an individual,
imposing discipline on himself,
guess what he'd doing during the battle of bulge?
Ballo Bolger middle of the winter,
snowed in,
don't have winter gear.
They're freezing.
They're dying.
What's winners doing in the morning?
He's up and he's shaving.
He's getting up in his shame,
his battalion commander comes.
I was like,
Bro,
are you sure you need to shave?
He's okay.
Just holding them on.
So
that's why we wrote the dichotomy of leadership.
This stuff has a balance and you have to learn to balance.
You don't want to end up going in,
ending up like captain.
So bell and I hope everybody that's has that tendency to want to control things
and they want to use discipline and they want to use unmitigated daily
discipline.
All things.
You want to use that as your slogan to beat people down.
Go Watch the first episode of Band of brothers and get your act together.
You,
yeah,
the fry.
That reminded me of when you were talking about your gym floor.
Yeah,
yeah.
Don't,
I mean,
sure.
You don't want the,
you don't want a bag and your dirty clothes and socks and shoes all over the
floor while you worked out,
but at this for a reason.
Yeah,
same way.
The whole reason you got to clean the flyers or the fryer for a reason,
whatever the reason is.
I'm not as familiar with priors,
but I'm sure I work at Wendy's like I did.
I can tell you that the external,
the external cleanliness of the fryer is not a big deal.
Like you said.
Do you want it to be caked with Greece where it's a fire hazard?
No.
Yeah,
but guess what?
It's a functional item that you're using all day.
Right?
There's going to be some spots on it and if I'm freaking out about that,
guess what?
I got somebody that's not washing their hands.
Or even worse,
I got someone that's intentionally sabotaging food.
So we get
bad reviews.
Now we're going out of business or whatever.
Yeah.
So it's essentially like,
hey man,
identify the youth,
the optimal use of the fryer and let's target that is like the the right way to
clean it kind of thing.
You know?
And that's sort of it.
Like don't,
you don't have to sweep your gym floor and mop it and make sure that you can see
your face in the,
I'm getting more chalk on that thing in 23 hours,
22 hours.
It makes no difference to why I have a gym floor,
the gym floor,
so I can drop weights and walk.
That's it kind of thing.
Not so you know,
I can,
I don't know,
be super disciplined,
wasted my time mopping it and you know all this stuff because I'm unmitigated
daily discipline and all things,
you know,
you have a functionality you have to uphold.
Imagine how many hours of my life I would've thrown away if I was mopping,
cleaning,
sweeping,
and vacuuming my gym floor every day when I got,
they would take as long as my workout would take.
Probably 20 minutes I guess.
Yeah,
so there's,
there's what,
almost two hours a week to a little over two hours a week.
Gone,
gone.
You think I got two hours a week.
Think about what two hour,
two hours is like a massive amount of time.
That's a,
that's a good two hours is a huge amount of time.
Unless that away you own a commercial gym,
then you want a mop that floor because it adds to the functionality.
Jim Getting members,
you know you're gonna,
you're going to get,
the floor's going to be clean.
Yeah.
But guess what?
Here go to the extreme.
Hey we just cleaned that floor.
Don't walk on it.
Jim is shutdown cause we just mopped it.
It's like,
no,
you just mopped it.
We're gonna use it.
Yeah.
So it's kind of,
at the end of the day,
it's kind of like what?
Unmitigated daily discipline in all things that what that are functional,
that are functional for sure.
That our,
our our for yourself for put that on yourself.
You put that on yourself and here's,
here's you really want to take this to the next level.
Yes.
Be disciplined in how you impose discipline on people.
Don't just let it run wild.
You have to have discipline in it.
That's the way it is.
Yeah.
It kinda does some paint that picture how you're saying,
every time I get these questions it's like,
I'm so happy we wrote the dichotomy of leadership because there's the answer.
That's the answer.
The answer is this.
All this is a dichotomy.
Everything is done and people don't want it to be at like a dichotomy because
it's dichotomies are complex.
Dichotomies are haired dichotomies take.
It takes skill to learn to balance and it takes awareness of the situation.
Yeah.
It's hard.
It's so much easier to say,
oh,
you just impose your discipline and make everyone do you want him to do.
You can't do that.
You'll end up with a mutiny.
My,
my second platoon that went when we had a mutiny,
we worked for a guy that made us do everything his way,
my way or the highway.
Guess what didn't work unique
is he was a highway,
but not for us.
For him.
Yeah,
and not a bad guy.
It wasn't a bad guy.
We didn't have bad intentions.
Hmm.
But that's where this guy's heading.
He said an ocs,
and if he keeps with that attitude,
he's going to end up in those situations.
The two beautiful.
I'm so glad he asked this question because I'm glad he asked this question
because it's not his fault.
He's listening to what I said and I didn't communicate it well enough.
So now he asked a great question and now he can take a much,
much better approach,
a much more balanced approach in his leadership
like flying a kite.
Can
your flow,
Kate?
I had flown a kite but this has nothing to do with Flint
because I get bring it back on the yard to no,
but the fundamental principle,
right?
You know,
you're not,
well,
depending on what kind of Kite I get it.
But you know,
the kind with the two handles,
the two strings,
you know,
you got to see what I'm saying.
You got to kind of pull one and let one go a little bit.
And then it depends on the wind.
You know,
it depends on how strong the wind is.
And you gotta pull crew,
let that slack out from telling you,
sure.
Fly a kite.
And I just flew on like maybe like five,
six,
seven weeks ago.
It's good.
Windy Day,
cold by the way.
Next question.
As a leader,
do you ever confide in anyone or seek counsel from anyone or do you just wrestle
with issues within yourself and try to figure things out on your own?
Another really good question.
And I do both of course
try and figure out things on my own.
But here's the little
secret.
Is it a secret?
It's not really a secret cause I'm about to tell everyone.
Sure.
But it's something that I wouldn't really talk about because it's just something
I'd wouldn't sink that we do.
Uh,
when I'm figuring things out on my own.
At the same time,
I,
I seek counsel and they not only said seek counsel from the trusted teammates
that I have or peers or superiors or,
or subordinates that I trust.
Okay.
But why,
when I counsel them,
when I,
when I see council,
when I ask for feedback,
while I'm trying to figure out things on my own,
I actually keep those thoughts to myself.
Hmm.
In the beginning,
right.
I let other people tell me what their ideas are.
First,
I want to hear what they come up with because if and if somebody comes up with a
good plan,
we're going with it.
Like if it's,
hey,
you know what?
That's pretty good plan.
We'll go with that.
Because as I've said many times I prefer to use one of my subordinates plan,
one of my subordinates planned over mine.
I would rather to use my subordinates plant rather than mine.
As long as it's tactically sound,
because then they,
they believe in their plan.
Right,
and if it's not tactically sound,
Yep.
I gave him a little nudge to make some corrections and still use their plan
because I want them to use their solutions and their plants so that way,
like I said,
they have ownership of the plan
and when they're coming
up with a plan,
guess what's going to happen?
They're going to get too close to it.
They're going to do what I talked about in that opening story,
which is they're going to,
they're going to be at low altitude,
they're going to be staring at it right in the face,
and I'm going to be allowed to remain detached and remain at altitude.
So I have a better perspective of the overall plan.
Then they do,
and that ends up making me look like a tactical genius,
which is awesome.
Hmm.
So the,
so I guess this is the secret.
This is the trick or whenever don't talk so much.
Don't talk so much.
Don't feel the need.
Don't feel the need is something you have to resist as a leader,
as a person that wants to be a leader.
They've always said some about people,
aspiring leaders,
right?
If you're an aspiring leader,
don't feel like you're the person that has to always come up with a plan or come
up with a solution.
Even when you are the leader.
Don't feel like you're that guy.
In fact,
it's better than not do that.
It's better just to,
to think into,
just listen to what people are saying and watch their plans come out and get
shot down and cook,
get reformulated and be improved.
And if you hadn't said anything yet,
guess what?
The longer you don't say anything,
the more people are gonna listen when you actually open your mouth.
So just kind of keep your mouth shut.
Now here's,
this is a little bit different because we're talking about like a plan,
right?
A strategy or something.
What if it's something political within your team?
You know what I mean?
Then what do you do?
What to use?
The same thing.
Like I will think,
I will listen,
I will discuss things with people and gather intelligence from them.
Ask them some probing questions,
but I'm not going to divulge what my position is because number one,
that will influence them.
It will make them react and I don't want to influence anyone or make them react
to until I'm going to be able to influence them and get them to react and act
the way that I want them.
That's going to benefit the team.
So
I'm going to ask some questions.
Hey,
what do you think about,
hey,
what do you think's going on with Jimmy?
Is He,
he seems to be accurate as he,
okay.
I'll ask you.
I'll ask him.
I'll ask Mike.
I'll ask bill.
I'll ask Jennifer Wolf.
I'll find out what's going on.
What's on our old Jennifer and bill.
They say something a little bit different.
Oh,
okay.
See,
I'm going to gather the political perspectives and
listen.
I'm going to let things unfold.
I'm going to observe
and relax and detach and listen and think and calculate.
That's what I do and dichotomy.
If something needs to happen and I have to be decisive,
I'm going to make a decision.
We're going to go with it.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna put it out there.
So oddly enough,
as a leader,
don't talk so much.
I know that seems crazy.
Hmm.
More talk.
The less people listen.
What about in like everyday stuff?
I guess maybe this wouldn't really apply to as a leader,
but maybe like as a person,
you know how like,
like you,
uh,
you know,
[inaudible] hall,
like I'll have a prop come in and it'll be like,
hey,
let me get your advice,
whatever,
about some thing that obviously it didn't feel like appropriate to just ask all
my friends kind of thing,
you know?
Like,
do you ever do that?
No.
You just mainly think about it yourself.
What I would do is,
you know,
I do what I,
what I just said I would do,
I'd be like,
hey man,
what's going on with this?
You don't know.
I guess if you were,
it's you when you come and ask me something,
you're asking me something.
You always ask me about something I'm not a part of in any way.
It's different.
So yeah,
if it's like that,
if it's something I'm completely,
if something,
if there's someone that's completely outside the situation,
yeah.
I'll say,
hey,
this is what's going on.
You know,
this,
what's going on here?
We had this happen,
I got this situation and just,
yeah,
for sure I'll do that.
Yes.
So that is,
that is good.
But um,
but if it's within the team,
then I generally just won't come out and ask like,
Hey,
what do you,
you know,
I want to change this.
Instead I'll be like,
hey,
what do you,
what would you change about,
you know what I mean?
Ask them what they think first because you might have to make some adjustment.
If I come in and is like,
Echo,
we're changing the way we record this thing now here's what's happening.
And you're like,
oh,
okay.
Then you're listening and the first thing you say to me is like,
that doesn't make any sense now.
I feel now I'm an idiot.
Especially when you say,
well,
here's the,
here's why it won't work,
Jocko.
Boom,
you lay out three things.
Instead of,
I was like,
hey man,
what would you think about this issue that we're having?
What solutions do you think we could do to solve that?
And all of a sudden I get to listen to your ideas.
And by the way,
when you come up with one of those ideas and one of them sounds pretty good to
me,
guess what we're doing
now?
Who's got ownership of that idea now?
He's all fired up to implement it.
You do.
And I didn't waste any leadership.
In fact,
I gained leadership capital because now you're like,
man,
Jack was,
are you?
Trust me dude.
It's pretty cool.
He's letting me run this.
Yeah.
And as speaking from person who doesn't necessarily,
well it doesn't seem like I necessarily get that big of a pay off to have that
to look,
I'm running this,
you know,
like an hour.
I don't know,
for whatever reason didn't,
I didn't never felt like that was a big thing to me to be the guy running it.
But I don't know,
maybe it is maybe in my subconscious because I know that you do that to me and
I'm,
that's why it's actually kind of funny because you don't do it in beat with big
things necessarily.
You know,
may,
maybe you will,
whatever.
But most of the time it's just some little teeny small thing.
And I'm like,
ah,
yeah,
you know,
just totally falling,
not falling for it.
I get it.
You know,
it's,
it gets a good tactic.
But now that how you just Felita to illustrate it and meanwhile,
I should know this.
I
do know this really,
that you do that it's not a bad thing.
No,
I'm,
I'm smashing you over.
It's actually perfect.
Yeah,
I'm not,
I'm actually,
um,
it's actually beneficial to you.
You're actually actually are running things,
you know,
if I come in and say,
hey,
we're,
you know,
hey,
what do you think kind of table we should get for the podcast or what,
you know what I mean?
What do you think?
We think it would be the best lighting system.
You know,
like,
I know what I think that's the,
see that's the thing I don't really divulge is I know what I think.
Yeah.
And you know what though,
which I know,
I understand,
but by the way,
the table thing that I tried with on that one,
they didn't want it little bit,
little bit.
Actually I failed because I should've put much clearer parameters around the
table scenario.
And for those of you that don't know what we're talking about,
which is no one in the world except for us too.
We had,
we got a different table for our,
for our recording studio,
which is right at this moment being expanded and but when,
when we were still in the small recording studio,
I forget why we needed a new table just cause the other one was too big.
No,
we're adding another camera.
Okay.
We're adding another camera and possible guests.
So yeah,
so hey,
say hey man,
you know,
go across the table.
And the one,
the table that I had gotten in the past,
let's face it,
it was legit.
It was legit.
Echo goes and gets a table.
I don't know if that thing costs $48 but it wasn't worth it.
This thing was a wiggly and small and weak and a,
anyways,
that's an example where I didn't do a good job.
And it's also an example of occasionally your,
your vision isn't aligned.
Like my vision.
Normally you and I have very aligned vision about something,
you know?
Well when it comes to the technical nature of what the podcast,
the table we weren't on,
I wouldn't have bought that table ever.
Well I wouldn't have bought that table for like a,
like a prop to be used in a one scene scenario
that,
but,
well,
okay,
so I'll admit,
I don't know if I told you this,
but I'll admit that the thing is you probably,
when you got your table,
you probably went somewhere and was like,
yeah,
that's the table you felt it and was like,
I can imagine in your eyeball.
Actually I actually ordered it online,
but I,
I'd say I have more,
even though I know you worked for a moving company.
Nonetheless,
I think I have more
um,
more worldly when it comes to furniture.
You might be right cause there's something wrong.
I saw it on Amazon.
I was like,
hey,
that's a cool table and that,
that fits the dementia.
It fit the dummy.
Yeah.
When it came in,
it's the old story,
you know?
Oh it looked good in the picture.
It'll kind of thing.
Then when it shows up,
it's like,
yeah,
you're like,
that looks good in the picture and it's only $39 she lasted,
the other table we had was 1000 bucks.
Yeah.
Alright.
It wasn't a thought.
It wasn't there.
She put a minimum price to ensure quality price to ensure some kind of quality.
Yeah.
Anyway,
the point is yes.
When you give somebody,
you let it be their idea.
You keep your ideas to yourself.
I'm not trying to be all secretive.
I'm not trying to be all secret.
It's not a cop.
I'm going to tell this person because eventually my idea is if it needs to come
out of it comes out.
Hopefully it doesn't come out.
Hopefully it never need to come out because my team comes up with a great plan
and I can just be quiet and they can go execute it.
That's my goal.
Yeah.
Occasionally they can't find a solution and it's like,
hey man,
you okay?
Hey guys,
and then maybe you don't.
I'll do.
I won't even divulge my whole idea.
I'll say he will.
What about you?
What about this?
What am I an idea like this?
Oh yeah,
that's not bad.
And Man,
when you see someone get a good idea,
they get so happy.
Yes.
It's so rewarding.
And so you want to give them that gift.
And the way you do that is by letting them come up with their own ideas.
You just gotta make sure that they have a worldly experience with furniture.
That's the situation.
Well,
they go and I dig it and cause in a way it's not really even about the idea.
It's more about,
okay,
we need a solution to this problem.
I don't care what the,
you know,
there's a bunch of potential solutions kind of thing and yeah,
you might have one in your head,
but you don't want to just start saying we're just throwing it around as the one
it also.
Yes,
you're right.
Also,
when you divulge your idea,
guess what happens to everyone else's ideas?
Especially when you're in a leadership position.
When you're in a leadership position and you devote your idea,
everyone kind of gravitates towards that idea as being the best.
If you keep your idea to yourself,
you let the true growth of ideas develop.
True things come out when people aren't just trying to say like,
oh great idea Jocko.
Yeah.
Even even if they're not like a kiss ass but you just,
you just put an idea in their head and they can't see it a different way,
you know?
And even if they do,
you put them in a position where now they have to shut down your idea and not a
big deal,
but it's still an added element that you have to,
you know,
you gotta kind of put them in as part of that position goes.
Yeah.
Rather than you,
you'll just kind of open up the floor.
It's kind of like backing,
you know who,
who else I'm going to say kind of kind of atmosphere,
you know,
and we all can,
throw around ideas and the best one comes up.
There you go.
Thanks Brian.
Cool man.
I'll get a better table next to him,
I promise.
Next question.
As we get ready to graduate from college,
I would appreciate your input on the following question.
I've always loved to take part in a variety of projects and I have ended up in a
leadership position in multiple organizations,
be be it in student,
VC firm,
the student body,
my professional fraternity,
et cetera.
In a way,
this is,
this was natural to me.
It's about extreme ownership.
Right.
I love what I was doing and you shouldn't just slough off that,
that phrase.
Oh,
it's about extreme ownership.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
That's how it should have been said.
Okay.
It is.
All this stuff is about extreme ownership,
right?
Can't be that hard.
Right.
Kind of kind of,
uh,
of course the motor shit.
Right.
Okay.
I loved what I was doing.
I had a vision where to take things and I was chosen to lead,
so I felt that I was doing the right thing.
Recently though,
I've started to feel overwhelmed and feel that my productivity has diminished by
being in a managerial position.
It seems harder to see the direct output of my work,
but it's as easy.
It is easy as always to see what's not working.
I don't want to be let go of any projects because I'll still love to make love
to take ownership of them.
Nobody says,
I don't want to be liquid,
says I don't want to let go of any projects because I still love to take
ownership of,
Oh yes,
yes,
I'm identifying symptoms.
Yeah,
you liked the word ownership.
That's like a like a really,
I definitely like the word ownership and as you also know,
I also like another word that's dichotomy.
Dichotomy,
seen violations here.
All right,
well either either way,
this guy,
he,
he doesn't want to let go of any projects because I still love to take ownership
of them and lead these organizations,
but I think I have no longer able to handle this much.
How do you balance those things?
Yeah,
so there is a chapter
in the dichotomy of leadership called own it all,
but that's not the title of the chapter.
So the title,
the chapter continues,
the title,
the chapter is owned it all comma,
but empower others and it sounds like this individual who's getting after it for
sure.
Props getting after it.
Leadership position,
multiple organizations going hard,
taking ownership.
Very cool.
But it sounds like he needs to lean more towards decentralized command because
just because you take ownership of things doesn't mean you're supposed to do
everything that you take ownership of.
It doesn't,
it doesn't actually doesn't work.
What this,
what you need individual is you need subordinate leaders inside these multiple
organizations that you're in charge of,
that you trust and you got to let them run with the broad guidance and the
mission,
the broad guidance of the mission and with your Commander's intent that that's
how you're gonna work on this.
So for instance,
when I was in charge of training on the west coast,
I was responsible for a lot of stuff for land warfare,
for maritime operations,
dive operations,
air operations,
close quarters combat,
urban warfare training,
mobility training,
heavy weapons,
defensive tactics,
combat leadership in every other block
for guys that are getting ready to deploy to Iraq and Afghanistan.
Oh.
And on top of those tactical things,
I'm in charge.
I'm actually also in charge of safety and actually also in charge of maintenance
and actually also in charge of the administration of the command.
That's a lot of stuff to be running,
right?
I know that homes is in charge of,
you know,
the the VC firm and the student body,
this,
that stuff too.
This is a lot of stuff.
Could I personally manage and conduct all of those things that I was in charge
of?
Not even close,
not even close,
not you.
You're talking about feeling overwhelmed.
You wouldn't last 15 minutes if you tried to be the person that made every
decision and all those different divisions that were inside of the training
command.
So I couldn't manage and run them all myself,
but I had great leaders that I trusted that we're going to make things happen
and I gave them the broad guidance of what we were trying to do,
what they're part of the mission was the parameters that they were allowed to
work within and then go get some and it's the same thing.
Task you to commander to I was tasking and commander got two platoons,
plus you've got a squad of of augmentees plus you've got CBS and you've got an
intel fuse in the sale and you got interrogators and you got radio
communications crew and you've got the it crew and you've got,
you've got the whole tactical operations center that you're running.
And it's the same thing.
Like I can't run all that.
Nope,
no human can run all of that.
So what do you do?
You have subordinate leaders that have the broad guidance.
They understand what the mission is,
they understand the commander's intent,
they go forward and get after it and they,
they know the parameters and sometimes they have issues and when they have
issues you can step in and you give them a hand or sometimes they get all of our
box.
You've got to put them back in the box.
But it's the same thing.
Even right now I've got Ashkelon Front,
we've got the podcasts,
we've got the,
the store got the supplements,
the peril of online training common out.
We got the t,
the real estate,
the gym.
We get the list goes on and I can't,
I can't run all those things.
But I caught people bleeding those things and run on those things.
And I could do the same thing.
It's like,
Hey,
here's the guidance,
here's the mission,
here's the commander's intent,
here's the sanity check on something.
Here's the parameters we're trying to move within
and then go,
go and get some.
So if you do well with decentralized command,
you can handle a lot now to could you possibly bite off more than you can chew?
Yeah,
you could get involved in so many things that you don't even have time to
monitor the situations at all and you don't have time to tell when people are
getting out of their zone or out of the parameters that they're allowed to work
within.
Or you don't have time to help when something goes sideways,
you don't have.
So you could get there and that will happen especially quickly if you have
failed to train and mentor and give directions and give guidance to the leaders
that you have that are actually on the front lines run and things.
So
that's part of it.
Now the other part of it is you can't do any of this if your ego will allow you
to let things go.
I mean,
you literally said,
I don't want to let go of any projects.
I've said this before.
If you want to be in charge of everything,
you have to be in charge of nothing.
You're goal should be in charge of nothing.
Only if you're in charge of nothing can you truly be in charge of everything?
Because when you're in charge of every single thing,
guess what?
You can handle nothing.
You're task saturated.
It doesn't work.
So
that's what you need to do.
Get some good solid leaders,
subordinate leaders,
empower them,
train them,
trust them,
make sure they understand where they're going.
Make sure they understand what the mission is.
Make sure they understand what the goals are,
make sure they understand what things are outside the box that they need to come
and talk to you about,
and then let them rock and roll.
Boom.
Do One more question.
My wife and I suffered three weeks of turmoil,
which including losing,
which included losing a child.
How do I expedite that moment when we pick up ourselves,
pick ourselves up and keep moving forward because I'm done sulking and we need
to move forward basically how to push through.
So
I mean obviously that's heartbreaking and I can't even imagine the pain that you
are going through in this situation.
And it's one of those things,
we've talked about this before.
The fact is we don't really have a cultural protocol for what to do.
Okay.
When we lose a loved one
and you have to basically make up that protocol.
I can't,
I can't dictate what that protocol is going to be for you.
But I can tell you some things from my perspective,
from some of the things that I've been through.
I can tell you my perspective on
loss.
And the first thing is that you already know it's going to be wretched
and you're not going to escape it.
And that pain in this is,
this is something that I've identified.
The pain that's going to come,
it's going to come in waves.
And at first you won't even notice that their waves because all the waves are
going to be so close together and they're going to be so continual and they're
going to be right on top of each other and the pain and the sadness is going to
feel like it's so heavy.
It's going to feel like you are drowning in sorrow.
Like you're not going to get any air and like you're not going to be able to
escape that sadness.
That's what the waves feel like at first.
Okay.
And then at some point there's going to be a little break,
just a little break,
just a little bit of light in the darkness.
Something is going to make you smile.
Something is going to make you laugh.
Something's going to just show you just a little bit of light.
But I don't know when that's going to happen.
And then you're going to see that little,
that little smile,
that little light.
And then the uh,
another wave of pain is going to come back again and it's going to be strong.
And you won't have any control over it.
You won't be able to say,
no,
I'm,
I'm in the right now,
or I'm smiling right now.
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna go back there.
No,
you're not going be able to control it.
And that's scary.
It's scary because we,
we get used to as adults,
hey,
we can kind of get control of things and now all of a sudden you're not going to
have control.
It's going to hit you and you're gonna feel it.
But
again,
like a wave,
like a wave in the ocean that is going to eventually subside again and you'll
see a little bit of light and you'll get a little bit of a smile and you'll feel
okay for a second.
And then guess what?
Another wave's gonna hit you.
They might not be as strong as that other way.
Dea Wave.
And you might not even notice that it's not as strong.
But again,
you can't control your emotions and you'll find yourself,
this is what I'm talking about factually.
You're going to be sitting there and all of a sudden you're going to be just
crying uncontrollably.
That wave is going to hit you.
You're going to go from normal to just crying uncontrollably and being sad.
That's what's going to happen.
And it again,
in your mind,
you can be thinking,
I can't control,
this isn't,
it's a wave and you're,
you're at the mercy of this ocean of sorrow,
but don't let that scare you.
Yeah,
don't let that scare you cause I'm telling you that that wave is going to
subside again and this is going to go on.
It's going to go on and the waves,
they will become weaker.
And what you need to realize is just because the waves are becoming weaker,
this doesn't mean that you love your child less or you miss them less or that
you rushed at their passing.
It just means that you're starting to be able to deal with it,
which is what you're supposed to do.
And as the waves get weaker,
which they will,
they'll also appear less frequently.
And again,
that's okay.
It doesn't mean that you don't think your child all the time.
It just means that it's being dealt with.
And while this is happening,
while you wait when you can,
when you start to when the,
when the storm waves start to calm a little bit,
what you can do is you can row the boat,
can row the boat.
And what I mean by that is start doing something productive to get your mind
moving forward.
I don't know how long this is,
this,
this is,
you know,
when you feel a little bit of a break,
then let's do some a few days go by,
five days go by,
three days go by.
At some point you can't cry anymore.
Okay,
let's do something productive.
Let's sort out the drawers in the bedroom.
Let's back Qm,
let's finish a product.
Let's do something productive.
And if there's something
that distracts you,
that's fine.
Do it.
Let,
let,
let there be some calm in the water
and also
as the,
as the calm columns.
Also you're going to find moments where it's like you can,
you can have things that are going to bring all of the waves
and that's okay to bring on the waves.
Go look at the pictures right down the memories.
Read the letters,
read the notes,
read the emails,
remember?
And then there's that standard service.
You're going to do the memorial,
you're gonna do the burial.
And when that's over,
let a little bit of more time go by.
Give yourself another week
of Washington around
of feeling that sorrow of letting the waves
toss you around in the ocean.
But after another week,
what you do is you go and you write a,
you write a letter to your child.
When you explain to them,
explain to them how much they meant to you.
Explain to them how heartbroken you are that they are gone.
And then explain to them why you are going to carry on,
why you are going to keep going
with them in your heart.
Explain to them why you're not going to dwell in their loss
and explain to them how in losing them you have learned without a shred of doubt
how truly precious life is,
and that they have taught you
the immeasurable value of your own life and your wife's life and your family's
life.
And explain to them that you know
that you know that they loved you and that you know that they would want more
than anything for you to be happy and productive and impactful in the world.
Yeah.
Then explain it in that letter,
what you will do to make them proud of how you live your life,
and then take that letter
and go to their grave
and read it to them
and cry
and kiss their soul
and tell them that you'll see them on the other side
and then
go live your life.
And those waves are still gonna come
and they're still going to be pain and they're still going to be sorrow,
but you go and live your life and live it well
and make them proud.
And I think that's
all I've got for
tonight.
So
go
ahead,
ma.
Yeah.
Like something like that.
He's like,
it doesn't always have to be like with,
you know,
losing a child that can be losing anyone.
Yeah,
for sure.
Like,
uh,
my wife had,
you know,
she lost someone that she was close to whatever.
So even if you're not in the,
or if you're in a situation where someone's close to you,
like lost someone,
it's good to keep like something like this in mind,
you know,
that it's going to come and go.
You know,
cause it's easy to be like,
Oh yeah,
like,
oh yeah,
they're over it,
you know,
so it's Kinda cool now.
And then it comes back and you're like,
wait,
I thought you were over it kind of thing.
Like he can't.
Yep.
That's an unfortunate lesson I've learned is yeah,
there's just that.
Yeah.
And you think it's,
it's a really great description of what it feels like.
It feels like waves.
If you surf or you've been in the ocean and,
and we've been getting hit by waves and like there's nothing you can do when
that wave hits you,
you're going to do what that wave wants you to do for little while.
Yeah.
And sometimes when it's bad,
like you're gonna get hit with a wave wave wave,
you can barely even tell you could come up for breath.
You're getting hit again.
Yeah.
And that's what it feels like.
It feels like.
And,
and the other weird thing is you can be,
you can go from one extreme emotion to another.
It in a minute,
you can be laughing and that laughter can trigger,
uh,
thoughts that make you sad and you get hit with a wave.
Yeah.
And one thing,
and I think this is important,
is that
okay,
you knew,
you know,
when I've talked about like the,
the person that's in a turmoil in their heads,
in a cloud of like a storm cloud.
And no matter where they look,
they,
they just can't see.
They don't see that there's a way out to anyone that's standing on the outside
can see like,
no,
come on,
just walk over here.
Just just get away from that storm cloud.
You can do it.
But when they're standing in the middle of,
they don't even know which way to walk.
So they just stand there and they just sit in a storm cloud and they think that
they're never going to get out.
And it's the,
it's the initial feeling after losses,
like,
oh,
this isn't gonna go away.
And what I'm telling you is it's going to,
and there's a certain level of guilt of like,
wait a second,
how can I be not thinking about it?
I just didn't think about this person for five minutes.
I,
I'm a,
I'm horrible.
It's like,
no,
you have to process this.
Yeah.
And no one wants you to dwell on this.
No one,
they never want you to forget,
but they don't want you to dwell as well.
There's a dichotomy in that
and that that's why,
you know,
obviously it's heartbreaking to get that note,
but hopefully you know that that recognition that those waves are going to
subside eventually.
There,
Stu,
you're still gonna get hit with some of them,
but
they are,
and it's okay that you're going to that,
that they're not going to be there.
Yeah.
Rough.
Yeah,
man.
For sure.
But you know,
when I,
when I wrote [inaudible] Mike and the dragons,
I,
I have the,
you know,
the king dies.
Yeah.
Right.
The king you,
you don't know him,
but the king is dead.
Yeah.
And there are certain people,
you know,
I figured if I,
if I actually thought to myself like,
well,
do I really want to talk about death?
Right.
And there's also,
there's a couple of lines with a dragon to want to kill you.
You know,
the dragon's want to kill,
right?
Yeah.
There's a couple times was thinking,
well,
do it,
you know,
this is a kids' book,
but here's the deal.
There's little kids that's parents dies that grandparents die.
I mean those,
the death is a real death is 100% part of life and you gotta learn,
you gotta learn how to deal with that.
Yeah.
Or else there's going to be a,
you know that,
and I'm not saying you got to dive into it with a little kid.
Right.
But you have to at least they have to hear the word.
They have to understand that that's a reality.
Yeah.
So yeah.
That's good.
Oh my God.
This video is like yesterday or the day before that,
my wife took him,
my son,
he had a dragon costume on.
It's too,
by the way.
And he's like,
oh I'm going to go kill Daddy.
It was like Whoa,
kill.
Like where did he even kind of,
and it's the reason I bring that up cause the dragons that are ready to kill,
right?
Yes.
That's from the wine making the dragon.
Cause that's kind of how you feel.
You know,
even though you don't know as a kid,
however old,
whatever,
you don't know what the magnitude of that is.
But you know,
you know like,
well,
what are you scared of?
The whatever the unknown.
Sure you're,
but you're scared of the monster in the closet.
Why are you scared of him?
Not because he's going to bore you to death with bad jokes or like he's going to
kill you.
That's what you're scared of.
You know,
kind of thing has,
even if you're six years old kind of thing.
So yeah,
man may make sense for sure.
Even think about what you kill a bug,
right?
Yeah.
Like a little kid get,
they kill a bug there eating a chicken.
The chicken was alive and now it's dead.
You're eating it right.
The death is a real thing and you have to,
you have to,
you have to deal with it.
You know?
And like I said,
we don't have a great protocol.
And I know we talked,
we joked about making a protocol for breaking up with a girlfriend.
A little bit more lighthearted for sure.
But I'll tell you what,
hey look,
you talk about lighthearted,
breaking up with a girlfriend.
Think about the tragic situations you've seen unfold from somebody breaking up
with their girlfriend or breaking up with her boyfriend.
Yeah,
it's horrible.
And there should be a protocol and there should be a protocol for,
hey,
lost a loved one.
Here's the protocol,
here's what I'm going to do.
And you know what part of that protocol should be,
you write a letter to that person and you explain what I just said.
That is a real,
uh,
that,
that will clear a lot out of you.
It will bring you in touch with that person again.
It'll give you permission from them to,
to go and do what you're supposed to do.
You have to,
they want that,
you know,
they want that.
Yeah.
Cause I'm like,
it kind of feels like,
Hey,
I'm going to go,
I dunno,
I'm going to go back to school or something like that.
It's kind of like,
Whoa,
how can you think of what my back to school when you're,
you know,
when you,
when this just happened kind of thing.
That's what you feel like,
you know?
But yeah,
on the other side is kind of like,
no.
Yeah.
That would,
that's what,
that's what they would want you to do kind of thing.
It doesn't feel like that.
But when you kind of step back and be like,
wait,
it does kind of feel like that,
you know,
if you can see,
just see fit to see it that way.
Rough.
Well to those out there,
eh,
um,
stay strong.
Yeah.
Live your life.
Cool.
Well we can talk about origin.
You know,
it is a rough transition.
There's bear with me talking about living and living well,
we want to live well.
Yeah.
We want to move forward.
So
is Jujitsu party your life?
That's a question you can ask.
Just there's no way.
There's no good way to do that.
I know.
And just saying,
Hey,
okay.
Origin origin,
main.com.
This is where you get your gear if you still need a gate or if you want a new
geek,
go ahead and get it from origin.
It's the best.
They're the best.
And they're made in America.
They're not necessarily the best because they're made in long term venture
there.
No,
I'm telling you and reminding myself why I really like origin geese.
Shit.
It just busted one out the other day.
No,
I was thinking you're really going for it.
You're like,
okay,
when I was thinking as you were doing that,
I was like,
Hey,
I'm sitting here telling people like,
hey,
sometimes you gotta you know,
you got to move on.
And we were literally having our time moving on,
just simply talking about this,
talking about the loss of a loved one and you're just like,
okay,
we're gonna move on.
Well,
and you just laughed.
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying that in a positive way.
Like you got to,
yeah.
Well this situation,
you know,
you got me talking about [inaudible] and just trained yesterday.
So it's like,
you know,
you kind of get a feeling good.
I feel good about that one.
It's true.
Yes.
Which is what did you do to does by the way.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's another thing.
It's like you gotta move on.
You got it.
You got,
you're going to go through a rough transition.
But like you said,
you got to look at your kid and be like,
okay,
we,
you've got to go back to school.
But what about,
you know,
what about my sister?
What about my brother?
What about grandma or whatever?
Whoever died.
Yeah.
That's part of life is death.
And we got to move on.
We're going to go.
Yeah.
And then they're going to reference Echo Charles Transition.
A rough transition to talking about Jujitsu keys.
All right,
but you see this,
I'm smiling,
so you know what I mean?
It's a positive thing.
Yes.
You're bringing me out that the reason we started doing the,
the,
the long extended support was to kind of decompress.
I remember there was some,
the first time,
I think it might've been a podcast number 12 now.
No it wasn't.
I don't know what podcast it was,
where I was like I need a break.
Yeah.
I just need to be like,
you need to talk for a little while,
but said something stupid and lighthearted.
Thanks for yeah,
no,
that's a compliment.
No,
it's not a compliment.
Especially Nike.
You just to talk.
But that was the reason.
Yeah.
Cause there's no way to refer.
How do you transition.
Yeah.
And the other thing you don't want to do is just close on that note.
Turn off and leave.
That's not cool.
Yeah.
So there's,
there's plenty of people that say thank you for going through the transition and
then guilt doing something a little more lighthearted at the end of the podcast.
Yeah.
So it makes sense.
I support that and we carry on with that tradition that your dish,
the rough transition.
I'm on board.
Cool.
So back,
did you get to the feel a solid,
good,
solid,
you know,
train yesterday thought about origin the whole time
[inaudible]
got after it.
And then the last,
even when you geek or a rash guard,
go to origin mean.com they have some other cool stuff on there as well.
Joggers,
if you're into it,
tee shirts,
if you're into it.
Supplements
that you need to get into.
And this is why.
So krill oil could joints.
Krill oil,
super.
A krill is what it's called,
joint warfare.
Discipline.
Go discipline.
Go milk.
All right,
discipline.
Go.
I'll tell you two minutes.
No,
I'll tell you the 30 seconds.
True discipline,
cognitive and physical enhancer drink.
Right?
Sure.
I really like it.
I liked
the way it makes me feel I for living,
one of my jobs is to go out and talk to companies and talk about leadership and
getting the game and do podcasts.
Like I gotta get,
you know,
mentally in the game.
Yes.
But going on,
talking to a company where I'm gonna be up on stage for two hours.
If I'm pounding some drink beforehand,
guess what's going to happen?
You know,
48 minutes in,
I gotta use the restroom.
I don't like to use the restroom.
That's a sign of weakness.
So I talked to Pete,
Brian,
I was like,
hey,
we need to take Watson disciplined and put it in a pill so I can just eat it
and,
and don't have to use the restroom.
48 minutes after I started talking to a company.
That's where discipline go came and it's awesome.
And not to mention you don't got to do the whole,
which I don't mind by the way.
I do like the ritual,
but the whole in the water in the mix and the whatever,
you know all that stuff.
If you're on the go there.
Yeah,
there you go.
That's why I discipline go and,
and we actually,
speaking of mixing,
we are going to,
we have a,
we have discipline in a can coming out,
which you won't have to mix.
You'll just crack it open bracket,
fit,
kind of.
And then mark of course,
if you need additional protein,
this lady get it.
Best Way to get it most pleasurable into the most delicious way to get a
delicious way to get it in.
I think a Ribeye has is an equally delicious,
although it's different,
cause I'm telling you this,
this makes me mad when I'm on the road and I'd go get a nice Ribeye and I'm
totally happy,
but I'm not,
I'm not totally happy.
I'm really,
I'm 96% happy,
but I want,
I want a little and a little,
you know,
just to kind of close the deal on my palette and I want something tasty.
Yeah.
What do they call it?
Savory.
My wife,
you say you do,
that's like salty,
right?
Oh,
what's like some sweet?
Yeah.
Have the savory Ribeye and then I'm going to close the deal with a little bit of
don't.
Well,
if you were like,
Hey,
I want some additional protein,
you don't go rebuy it because Ribeye,
you get additional protein,
additional whatever else,
nutrients in that,
which is cool.
But if you just want additional protein,
more isolated will say,
yeah,
boom.
Get the milk plus the sleep.
The pleasure for the pallets.
And if you've got kids and it's hard.
Look,
we got a problem in America.
I'll just throw it out there.
We've got kids that are just not eating correct.
They're out of shape.
Yeah.
So,
so what do you do?
What you want to get him?
Something that tastes good to eat?
What tastes good to eat?
Candy bars.
What else tastes good to eat?
Ice Cream.
Cheetos,
guess what?
Those are all bad for you.
Go guess what else tastes good to eat?
Warrior Kid Mohawk Warrior.
Get milk to drink.
Would you say,
would you say eat,
drink to drink?
But I mean,
yeah,
if you mix it thick,
you got yourself a little maps.
Basically food,
put some coconut shards,
a charge.
They go warrior,
kid bulk also at [inaudible] dot com by the way,
that's all this stuff,
all of that stuff.
But we do have a store,
we have a store Jocko store chocolate store.com if you want to represent the
path where some shirts more indicative directly to the path Jocko stored up
comp,
get after it.
Discipline equals freedom.
I was at 24 fitness.
I go there to lift sometimes,
maybe once or twice a week trainer.
They're in the game happens to be in the game yet found.
Now his name is Justin.
By the way,
a firefighter up in San Bernardino,
Yak.
He lifts up his shirt.
You know,
you have the trainer's shirt on.
He lifts it up,
get after it and sit down.
Good evening.
Uh,
the shirt.
Yeah.
There's sometimes people want to represent in a more covert covert way or he,
I mean they'll know what I'm saying.
Is def core.
Yeah.
If you want to see,
uh,
a sub,
a subtle way,
this t shirt that I'm wearing right now can only be beat,
can only be PID,
positively identified by someone that's completely in the game.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yes.
Yay.
Andy.
You,
yeah.
As you wear it and you're like,
hmm,
I'm a reasonable reason.
I got no reason to tell anybody what's up.
I know.
What's up def core check also plus truckers.
Hats.
Yes.
Or uh,
the other kind of hats.
Flex,
fit go equal.
Equal.
Don't,
don't discriminate against the flex fit.
They're equal.
Also.
Hoodies,
some beanies on there,
some women's stuff on there.
It's really good.
Yeah.
If you want to represent Jocko,
store.com some good stuff on there.
Also Jocko white tea.
Yeah.
Just having something in the can preferred by me.
But if you'd like to Caep is,
it's super steep.
Steep.
Yeah.
We're sure about this is seper word seeping out of linking.
So we're not leaking or snow being steep.
Steep,
like a steep hill.
There's,
yeah.
Multiple Meanings.
Samey,
same work.
And last if you'd like to steep the,
well,
what do you call the dry?
The bags.
I don't know the terminology,
but the tea bag.
It's good.
Teabag in the deal.
Yeah.
Cold,
hot,
whatever.
Anyway,
and you deadlift 8,000 pounds.
Yeah,
it's true.
I know.
I just added that as like a little thing,
but it's a big deal.
Also,
subscribe to the podcast.
If you haven't already on iTunes and stitcher and Google play and wherever you
listen to podcast,
there's a lot about the options.
People email me,
I don't know how they get my email of their new podcast out.
Say,
Hey,
put your podcast on our APP.
Doesn't that happen automatically?
Some,
yeah,
some.
Apparently I.
Here's the thing,
I don't know.
Evidently not because they're asking me to do it and don't forget about the
warrior kid podcast of which we just released a couple more.
20 and 21 are alive here.
Some questions for Uncle Jake and here's some stories from Uncle Jake,
him explaining how he got his values in life through stories.
Also got youtube.
Don't forget about youtube.
Youtube is where you can see this video of this podcast and then you can see
cool videos from Echo Charles that he makes on his computer thing and you can
check his style and give him feedback if he went too far.
I think there's,
there's some videos that violate good tastes.
There's only one really only a couple of it is Christmas.
Don't Christmas is coming up.
I'm going to read it.
At least I'm going to repost it.
I'm going to remind everyone is that still live?
It's live video.
In fact,
people have been contacting me and say they appreciate it.
Or is that war?
It's a war path.
Is it called the war panel?
Christmas videos called the war path.
You need to into junk or what's the other one called?
Revised mean cause then you made a good one,
uh,
one without one with different music,
some slight variation.
Anyway,
thanks for you know,
saying that nonetheless.
Well,
that song is right up there with your podcast table
noted just saying their psychological warfare,
which has an album with tracks and it'll kind of help you get through some more
off moments of weakness,
more than kind of help you a lot.
100% proven by echo.
Whose has moments of weakness?
I have moments for sure he overcomes them.
Yes.
Especially with the stuff you're talking about.
I mean,
yeah,
not so much with the eating donuts thing,
but like waking up or getting up.
Like you know,
that's a,
I have a deep history waking up.
If I don't have to wake up for somebody specific,
like you know,
you'll be like,
hey I got to get up cause I got gotta I can't even remember what it's like to
have my why's opened up in the morning and not feel the defier not,
I'm not talking,
I'm not talking like I'm not trying to say I wake up in the morning,
I have this internal fire.
I'm talking about the heat from external sources of thanks,
I got it new.
Right.
So I'm going to get you the connoisseur of comfort.
Echo Charles this often wake up and say,
hmm,
Yup.
So you know,
all is good.
Well,
thanks for helping me.
How about that?
And skipping workouts too.
Thanks for helping me with that.
Not skipping postponing.
That's the problem.
Postponing workouts.
No,
that's psycho thing.
I'm just gonna.
I'm just gonna not do it.
If you don't do a workout that doesn't get postponed.
It just got skipped.
No Ban.
No wall yet.
No,
he does get postponed because look,
if I'm going to do x movement,
this,
you know,
if I'm going to do that,
you know and I'm going to run it as it happened the same day.
No.
Okay,
then,
then you lost it.
It's going to have it kicking it back.
Okay.
Get it.
Actually,
you're right,
because look,
my workout goes day one,
day two,
day three,
day four,
day five.
Like in Dave is,
it's by day is what I'm saying.
So if I skip when you make a book of your workout,
how's that?
Yeah,
I have.
I have all the,
everything I have.
I made it long time ago.
I used to get into the name of the book.
It's going to be out to get chairs
with seven A's in the Jack.
All right.
Who's not going to buy that?
How give Jack Charles?
Nobody.
Everyone was going to buy it.
It apparently it's nonetheless kettle bell curls.
Back to barbell curls,
sandbag curls.
You do day two on day three,
you skip day two.
You went to date three.
Just cause you're reformulated the movements on day three.
It doesn't negate the fact that you've skipped.
It's one of was skipping work.
I'm just keeping running.
You won't do it anymore.
Psychologic warfare.
Also speaking of workouts,
improve very up your workout with on it stuff.
Put on it.com/jockey for kettle bells.
So it was on the yes Dave for yesterday.
Not yesterday.
Got some socks and some other cool items.
I need a rope though.
Get One.
I will.
And if you're getting things and get a book called Mikey and the dragons,
how's it being reviewed in your fam
reviewed?
Yeah.
What's this?
What's the like is a good,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well my daughter uses uh,
lines
in the giant.
Yeah.
Jamie just sent me a video of her daughter getting ready to go get a shot.
I saw that.
I watched the video with my daughter too.
She can,
we both enjoyed it.
Yeah,
but talking about you're going to be brave.
Yeah.
Actually says I'm going to be pretty brave.
Pretty cute.
I was scared last time but this time I'm going to be brave pretty much
but she's there.
I mean it's a story of how old she is,
what she's talking about Mikey and the dragons like you can understand this.
You can understand that how you can overcome your fears.
Miking the dragons.
Sorry it was out of stock but we in stock now.
Boy We got plenty of stock so order one for you.
Order one for be like Sarah in order 10 be like Andrew Paul and order 20 yeah,
I think it was Sarah was making fun of my math.
The Jocko math is like,
oh Andrew's going to order one.
Sarah was going to order one echo order one and when it's really like,
oh,
Sarah's going to order 10 you wonder why we went out of stock anyway.
We are fully in stock now.
We will not be out of stock again,
so Mike in the dragons,
get some and weigh the warrior kid both way.
The warrior could one and two.
Number two is called Mark was mission number three is coming out in the spring.
I will get it up for preorder and believe me,
I understand now why we preorder books.
Yeah,
I kind of made that mistake with Mike in the dragons.
You all please preorder when I put it up so that I know how many I'm going to
print or at least a decent estimate and I'll,
I'll take Sarah's order and multiply it times 10 times.
I'll set aside 10 for her and 20 for Andrew Paul and everybody else had ordered
stacks of those books,
so appreciate it.
Discipline equals freedom field manual.
How to get after it.
New Year's,
everyone's on their big river was at resolution.
Revolution both.
Let's do a new year's revolution.
Sure.
Pose the discipline because you can't just say,
well,
tomorrow I'm going to go on January 1st.
I'm going to change him know today.
Between now and then.
I'm going to keep slacking,
you know,
whatever.
That's kind of what you're saying.
That is what you all way of slacking too.
You could just get in the game right now.
Um,
extreme ownership.
Obviously reference that a bunch today and get the dichotomy of leadership so
that you don't just get one perspective and forget about the dichotomy.
You need the dichotomy.
He knew your world as a leader.
Echelon Front.
That's my leadership consultancy.
We solve problems through leadership.
We will come into your company,
assess and align your team so that they dominate.
Go to echelon front.com for details.
Yes.
Also the muster 2019 musters.
I will say when 19 Chicago,
Denver and Sydney,
Australia,
Jocko,
we'll be at all of them.
Yes I will.
I will be live and I will be getting and they've all sold out.
So you're thinking,
well,
you know,
I'll just,
I'll wait and see.
We are doing a podcast live,
live podcasts in New York City January 9th I will post the tickets as soon as
they're available.
If you haven't seen him yet,
check my,
what is it?
Social media platforms,
Instagram,
Twitter,
Facebook.
So you set that date aside.
It's a Wednesday night,
it's in New York City,
it's in a nice cinema or nice theatre theatre has the red velvet seats,
right?
Indicative they all,
sometimes people will say like,
did you ever think you'd be a children's author?
Or they'll say like,
hey,
did you ever think you'd be,
you know,
speaking to groups and I'm always like,
whatever.
I don't know.
Maybe I like writing,
but if they said,
hey,
jurors think you're going to be speaking in a symphony hall with Red Velvet
seats,
I'd say,
but I am.
And so were you go whether you like it or not.
So there's that.
Here's something new.
He f online,
[inaudible] online.
So
I guess I have to explain a little bit.
We have the muster,
we have the echelon front where we go and work with companies at the muster.
You travel and you go and it has a pretty high price point.
Some companies have a lot of people,
some people have smaller budgets.
As we recognize,
some companies asked us,
hey,
we want you to train everyone in our company.
We have 150,000 employees and they're located dispersed around the globe,
can you get that done for us?
This is one of those things where it's like,
no,
I can't,
we can't get to 150,000 people in a,
in a,
in a short enough period of time that it has the impact we want to deliver.
So with all that,
how do we overcome this barrier?
We go to technology.
So we've created online leadership training course.
It's calledF online.
It's going to be available through direct consumer.
If somebody will just want,
like for instance,
let's say you can't go to the muster for whatever reason,
this is a
virtual,
I guess it's a virtual muster,
uh,
or it's,
it's a sin.
It's a similar as simulation.
That's not saying,
yeah,
that's what it is.
That the original idea for me was,
uh,
you go to the monster without having to go.
You get that information,
get that interactivity without actually having to go to the muster.
So there you go.
Yeah.
If online,
and we made it for individuals,
we also have it for enterprise.
So we're,
we're now getting it.
We already have it with our clients,
they're stoked on it and so you have online.com it's going to be available g to
the masses,
New Year's Day,
January 1st,
2019 and of course there's eff Overwatch where we are connecting proven leaders
from Spec ops and combat aviation to companies in the civilian sector that need
combat proven and tested leaders,
experienced leaders to come in into their organization with the principles of
extreme ownership,
with the principles of the dichotomy of leadership and helping them lead and
win.
That's f overwatch.com whether you're a talent seeker,
a career seeker,
we are there for you and if you want to continue communicating with us,
we can be found and we can be communicated with on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram and on.
Dad pays eight ball that goes at Echo Charles and I,
m at Jocko Willink.
And finally thanks to all our folks out there in uniform.
Okay.
That includes,
of course,
our military that protects us from foreign threats.
And here at home,
our police and law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
and he empties correctional officers and Border Patrol and all other first
responders that keep us safe from evil doers.
And sometimes they keep us safe from the wrath of nature itself and to everyone
else out there,
life
can be hard in one of the hardest things that life can put you through his
death,
death of someone you care about.
And when that happens,
it is a reminder to all of us that the clock is ticking every day in every day
that we have here is precious.
When death visits upon your life and tries to rip you apart and drown you in
those waves of sorrow,
don't let it
drive on.
Drive on and live on for those that you have lost and live your life to the
upmost by getting out there every day
and getting after it.
Okay.
Can,
until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.